salut Stéphane salut à toutes et à tous
bienvenue pour ce chasser bol Masters ça
va être on va suivre ça ça fait partie
du champions c'est le deuxième tournoi
Stéphane on n'a pas trop les rêves parce
que les règles ont changé depuis l'année
dernière moi je les ai commenté à
l'époque de c'était un tournoi de Play
Magnus qui arrivait maintenant sur
chaise comme play Magnus et donc c'est
vrai que ils font des évolutions et donc
il tâte un peu pour essayer de trouver
la meilleure formule et voilà on va
découvrir tout ça en évidemment
je l'ai un peu regardé bon là j'ai un
petit souci j'arrive pas à suivre les
joueurs je vois que Magnus n'est mais
n'est pas en ligne oups
Artémis un gros gros client surtout en
blé sur Internet
donc c'est certaines parties enfin un
match en tout cas très très intéressant
tiens là je vois dans les joueurs il a
un beau score il a un beau score contre
artemief il est ici bien online on se
rappelle de ce championnat du monde
rapide ou Magnus avait fait une gaffe
assez incroyable qui perdait une pièce
alors qu'il avait 12 minutes contre deux
que comme ça et donc ça avait remis un
petit peu en cause son tournoi mais il
avait quand même emporté à la fin mais
voilà c'est vrai que il a il a décrit
artemief une fois en disant qu'il avait
un sublime style positionnel ça a beau
compliment de la bouche de du encore
champion du monde pendant quelques
semaines
et il est il est ouais il est pas là on
a aussi évidemment
ikaruna kamura qui se sont qualifiés du
dernier tournoi c'est un mix c'est un
mix entre les qualifier la dernière fois
c'est à dire les les deux finalistes de
la dernière fois les vainqueurs de la
division 2 parce qu'il y a plusieurs
divisions il y aura Maxime machin grave
qu'on va suivre aussi parce que texto là
je te laisse respirer un petit peu pour
que tu fasses la technique parce que
texto il nous a prévu ça avec
avec Maxime Vacher Lagrave qui jouera
dans la deuxième division mais deuxième
division c'est chaud et on a évidemment
des qualifié du playing dans lequel j'ai
joué malheureusement j'étais à deux
doigts de rentrer dans le dans la
division 3 mais pour quelques points de
départage rendez-vous compte j'ai fait
j'ai fait j'étais avec des cours avec
les gens qualifiés à la division 3 mais
voilà pour quelques points de départage
je suis pas qualifié j'avais qu'à
marquer un demi point de plus c'était
réglé mais bon c'est pas si facile
quand même le niveau du tournoi
il y a plein de joueurs qui ont arrêté
le tournoi ils pensent
on a vu Magnus a peut-être cessé sur mon
écran simplement on a vu Magnus Carlson
que je te donnais avant Stéphane Magnus
qui joue alors il aime bien dans ces
tournois online parfois en tout cas
voyager comme si il jouait un tournoi en
vrai et on le voit en fait là tu l'as à
sa caméra on va le voir bientôt il est
en France manuscrite il est dans les
Alpes alors je peux pas dire précisément
mais c'est un endroit où je suis déjà
allé avec lui en stage d'entraînement
qu'il avait apprécié donc il y avait sa
famille et son coach Peter Nielsen donc
voilà il se met en mode en mode montagne
le matin mais on sent quand même en
tournoi parce que on n'est pas à la
maison et c'est quelque chose d'assez
intéressant toujours Magnus Carson qui a
quand même toujours on voit une approche
quand même assez assez unique dans sa
dans sa manière de jouer dans sa manière
de se préparer
il réfléchit Magnus et il fait des
choses pas conventionnelles et qui
peuvent paraître surprenantes mais en
fait quand ils réfléchit bon après une
fois il m'a surpris et en fait quand
j'ai réfléchi je me dis bah ouais c'est
pas bête quand même
c'est un peu toujours ça tu vois c'est
pourquoi j'ai pas pensé avant ça paraît
tellement simple mais voilà donc il se
met dans des conditions de tournois en
en ayant évidemment du bon temps dans
les Alpes le matin parce que faut
rappeler pour moi commence à 17h ce qui
est quand même assez tard clairement
bon moi je trouve ça cool tu vois de
vraiment se mettre en condition pour un
tournoi comme ça genre il le prend
sérieusement et puis et puis voilà quoi
c'est cool et puis ça change un petit
peu aussi le cadre tu vois c'est un toit
sur internet mais tu es pas chez toi et
ça c'est exactement tu as dit tu sais
quand tu es à la maison c'est le cadre
que tu vois tout le temps tous les jours
et en fait
c'est comme des paysans quoi de d'être
ailleurs d'être à la montagne etc tout à
fait donc ça serait intéressant de voir
bon les Caro Nakamura évidemment il doit
être de chez lui parce que il stream il
a pas de temps à perdre et carreaux on
rappelle je sais pas si tu as suivi mais
il y a l'american's cup qui s'est
terminé récemment où il a encore gagné
c'est un tournoi mix entre classique et
partir rapide après s'il y avait un
partout au terme des parties classiques
il y avait des rapides il a gagné contre
ouais c'est chaud dans une fièvre et
puis qui était très très sympa donc
vraiment
Nakamura alors je te souhaite la même
chose Stéphane d'ailleurs tu as pas mal
ta cartonné ce weekend avec deux sur
deux
en National bravo
la partie contrat était
une position je donne un pion mais j'ai
mal jugé et en fait tout ce que je suis
pas bien et derrière j'ai blender un
deuxième pion en pensant faire le coup
de l'année et en fait c'était un gros
coup de faire
d'accord
mal Boyer qui s'est d'ailleurs qualifié
pour le le prochain Axel bravo à
l'équipe de canechet qui se qualifie
pour le
Top 16 de l'année prochaine on vous
attend de pied ferme chers amis cannois
j'aime pas les gens qui regardent leur
marche à prendre ou là j'aime pas ça
c'est dangereux donc voilà donc
icarbonakawa en tout cas et stream toute
la journée mais ces résultats sont très
bons donc voilà donc c'est plutôt toi
qui te met à streamer j'ai l'impression
quand même beaucoup
c'est plutôt rassurant je pense que ça
va être un exemple
ça veut dire que
finalement le vieil adage qui dit que
faire des Blitz c'est pas terrible
finalement
finalement ça va on me dit dans le chat
je te je te transfère le message ouais
on t'entend à peine donc en fait ça
c'est le c'est le host j'ai le même
problème Stéphane donc mets-toi mets-toi
plus fort dans le dans l'Obs alors ouais
ça m'est arrivé la dernière fois
[Musique]
un peu ouais comme ça et voilà l'autre
fois j'avais un problème j'ai vu que
est-ce que c'est mieux mon micro était
pas branché en fait c'est fou
le micro de frais qui est bizarre
attends est-ce que j'ai branché mon
micro
génial donc voilà ça va aller beaucoup
mieux vous allez avoir ensemble beaucoup
plus clair
moi je les connais
je suis désolé mais il faut le dire
merci à toi
allô
j'ai tout recadrer
on en revient à ça en tout cas on a
manucar sanica Mora et tant d'autres
artémises dans cette division 1 tandis
que Maxime et chagrin en division 2 mais
on a tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
en gros
dans quelques instants
et donc
on sait qu'il est qu'il est fort frais
c'est comme le PC un peu
ouais ça c'est l'arbitre et en fait
apparemment c'est pas si clair que j'ai
le droit de les de virer le son
absolument pas mal
je me sens moins moins
en tout cas il avait l'air ravi hein il
a il a vraiment on entend le stream
anglais ouais en fait c'est le c'est
l'arbitre qui parle aux joueurs d'accord
[Musique]
si j'enlève le son apparemment ça
pourrait faire un
générer un problème sur sur mon zoom
apparemment ce qu'on m'a dit et comme
moi en zoom bah je suis complètement
novice je préfère suivre les conseils
des professionnels premier jour on est
désolé mais bon là ils m'ont dit qu'en
fait ils m'ont dit qu'en fait il fallait
une une
qu'on met une je sais pas comment dire
une motorisation pour pouvoir mieux les
gens et comme j'en ai pas
voilà mais c'est pas un stream c'est
l'arbitre qui parle à carcène qui parle
à ce jour-là voilà
il y a aussi une petite vérification ils
font ils font visiter la pièce alors moi
qui l'ai joué ce playing je peux vous
dire que ils m'ont fait faire le tour de
la pièce où je jouais pendant pendant 3
minutes bon c'est un peu pénible quand
on le fait sur le moment mais
effectivement
ça ça permet de faire plus de choses de
fait d'être sûr qui est pas de qui est
pas très évidemment on m'a même demandé
j'avais deux caméras une caméra qui
filmait qui me filmait de profils avec
eux mes mains visibles à tous les
moments enfin vraiment je suppose que
c'était pas que pour moi j'espère mais
en tout cas
c'était pour tout le monde clairement il
y a des quand même des
un dispositif en titre riche assez
sérieux
donc on va voir est-ce que
est-ce que ça ça commence ou pas en fait
la partie vont commencer je crois que
dans l'oreillette il disait que ça
allait commencer à l'heure alors je
crois que eux ça commençait à 5h15 il me
semble et donc j'ai eu des j'ai eu
plusieurs
et j'ai eu plusieurs comment dire
ouais son cloche différent apparemment
toutes les commencent à 17h après j'ai
entendu dire que la division 2
commençait à 16h
voilà bon c'est un peu bizarre donc pour
raconter un peu con comment ça se passe
alors en fait simplement vous avez trois
poules donc poule 1 2 3 la poule 1 c'est
la poule avec les meilleurs joueurs donc
vous allez avoir je vais vous faire la
liste si vous voulez je l'ai ici vous
allez avoir
regardez j'ai un beau truc ça je peux te
l'envoyer si tu veux Laurent on a
artemief carcène qui se joue
Carlson leakwang fait de Sega Nakamura
un gros derby et aronyanso donc ça c'est
les 8 joueurs de la Division 1 et en
fait à confirmé Stéphane ce que je
pensais c'est un tournoi à double
élimination
bracket ensuite donc on peut se refaire
il faut faire ce match pour être éliminé
pour de bon ouais c'est ça et en fait
non c'est pas ça parce qu'en fait dès
que tu perds tu peux encore
il y a des oui oui non dans celui-là oui
donc en fait en gros si tu perds un seul
match je t'ai jamais éliminé ça veut
dire tu peux gagner jusqu'au bout c'est
ça c'est ça mais en fait dans le dans la
division 2 tu vas voir qu'en fait même
si tu perds ou à la deuxième manche à la
troisième manche il y a encore des des
losers et c'est ça en fait la complexité
du truc c'est qu'en fait dans la dans la
2 bon sans m'en faire un mais
en fait on a besoin qui va jouer une
Guiri on a regazi contre sa Douani on a
deux bof contre lasavik on a gamer
meilleur les deux joueurs ah
on va dire allemand mais c'est vrai que
meilleur est parti en Uruguay on a
l'étoile contre pragranda shigaev contre
o'parin contre
mvl qu'on va suivre d'ailleurs nous
aussi il y a 2-0 pour Maxime hein
ça a commencé ça commence à 16h bah du
coup ça va quasiment être fini si ce
qu'on va mettre 4 parties hein si elles
veulent fait une nulle
Maxime un peu plus tôt demain peut-être
demain en fait si tu veux moi on m'a
donné l'horaire 5 minutes avant que ça
commence et j'étais pas du tout demain
à Nathan évidemment mais moi ça me
semble
77 quand même c'est quand même sympa
surtout si il commence à Maxime c'est
toujours comme ça si il commence à
gagner surtout online il peut il peut
tout gagner il commence à perdre il peut
tout perdre donc c'est un joueur qui
joue avec beaucoup de confiance plus il
gagne mieux il joue j'ai un problème
j'arrive pas à suivre les joueurs
j'arrive pas à vous montrer les parties
donc je peux vous montrer les caméras
déjà des joueurs attendez je ça m'a tout
fait bugger mais je vais vous montrer
comme la caméra de avec les joueurs
c'est pas la partie parce que quand je
vais
dans
suivre les joueurs et que je clique sur
carcène il me dit que je n'ai pas le
droit de regarder la partie
je ne peux pas cette partie ne peut pas
être observée
et on m'a dit en plus de passer par là
donc
comment faisons-nous je ne peux pas voir
en fait
je ne peux pas peut-être si je vais dans
Game
il sait pas couper les cheveux mais il a
il a un truc pour attacher ses cheveux
comme ça
ça marche pas en fait je peux ça marche
pas je peux pas cliquer
je pense qu'on peut suivre les tournois
ouais effectivement Florent pour ceux
qui sont habitués c'est quand même le
site de des retransmission chez 24 ça le
reste pour le moment pour le moment
je vais essayer de notre méthode avant
il y avait un il y avait un chat je
pouvais écrire
vous pouvez avoir donc l'application et
le show qu'on est en train de diffuser
donc pour avoir les coups des parties et
voilà je vois je vois que Magnus a
commencé effectivement
j'ai pas accès aux parties une défense
là de la part d'artémia c'est toujours
comme ça il joue des Slaves artemief
c'est du 15 + 10 donc c'est quand même
des parties relativement longues hein 15
+ 10 on a quand même il y a pas de
panique à la fin moi c'est ce que je
regrettais un petit peu au planning
c'était du 10 + 2
et je dois avouer que d'un point de vue
très orienté et très très personnel les
deux secondes à la fin me suffisent pas
ça ça donne du grand n'importe quoi sur
les derniers coups ce qui est un peu
gênant quand tu as fait des une partie à
peu près correcte donc là 15 + 10 c'est
vraiment on a le temps d'aller jusqu'au
bout jusqu'à la fin logique je dirais
des parties
il me dit viens
ça joue ça joue tranquillement tes
miettes normalement qui qui joue les
ouvertures solides mais après qui prend
beaucoup de temps qui est assez lent
mais après il est très très bon quand il
a peu de temps la pendule ce qui peut
jouer des tours notamment quand on joue
contre Magnus mais normalement c'est
quelqu'un qui prend son temps
à peu près normale mais je suis à peu
près sûr que sur les prochains coups et
il va il va prendre beaucoup de temps tu
as vraiment aucune partie là du coup on
m'a donné un truc
mais là par contre je vais devoir vous
cacher mon écran
je vais présenter les matchs rapidement
on est à karwana Fabiano Carana face à
les conglium et qu'on Guillaume qui est
vraiment un tueur entre guillemets sur
internet très très bon joueur Fabienne
ocarwana ancien numéro 2 mondial ancien
challenge au champion du monde et
toujours un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde donc c'est ça va être passionnant
évidemment Nakamura fait dossiere de
joueurs très connu online évidemment et
car on a qu'à moi grand favoris dans ses
dans ces formats le streamer américain
probablement le pas celui qui a le plus
de réussite au monde tout simplement
avec Gotham Gotham
c'est assez incroyable les deux
carrières qui mènent de front et il joue
mieux en mieux en plus
et enfin ça fait aussi F qui est très
très fort grand maître
qui joue maintenant sous le drapeau de
la fidélité et ensuite on a le duel
entre américain entre Wesley sauts et
les vans à rognan
et donc très intéressant de joueurs du
Top 10 mondial depuis de nombreuses
années
avec Wesley qui est très très fort
normalement dans ces dans ces formats
parce que très dur à battre donc c'est
des formats de match et donc les joueurs
du rabattre et bien en général
ils vont loin c'est un joueur qui peut
vraiment qui peut vraiment
causer le trouble dans ce championnat
c'est un joueur qui peut clairement
éliminer un aka ou en gardien
bon après c'est vrai qu'il a eu ils ont
fait un duel magnifique dans cette
American Cup avec
Iker Honda Cameron c'était encore
doublémation donc icaruna camera a battu
ouais c'est sauts ensuite ouais c'est
soit a pris sa revanche et ensuite ils
ont joué dans le dernier dans le dernier
set ils ont joué à tie break epic ça
s'est terminé en blitz c'est une gaffe
de Wesley ou je trouvais qu'il joue un
peu mieux que Nakam et le truc c'est que
Naka a fait 0 gaffe et western a fait
une et ça ça pardonne pas
les parties quand tu fais une gaffe tu
donnes une pièce bon mais voilà c'est
terminé bon en tout cas ça y est je
t'annonce que j'ai lu ce qui est j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut je vais regarder un
petit peu parce que ça m'a tout changé
mais j'ai dû me loguer avec un compte
que qu'est-ce qu'on m'a prêté c'est un
compte qui est inconnu
normalement je suis avec tout et là je
suis avec un autre compte mais j'avais
un bug je sais pas de quoi d'ailleurs tu
sais pas c'est un peu comme sur sur
comment s'appelle zoom j'ai droit
d'avoir enfin il me faut des
autorisations pour pour enlever le son
de l'arbitre par exemple
et
là tu peux enlever quelqu'un l'a dit
dans le chat j'ai oublié de te le dire
tu sais que tu peux l'enlever sur l'ordi
je te montrerai après je sais comment ah
oui oui dans les paramètres audio
de Magnus qui dort donc voilà on a une
position ce que je disais on a une
position à peu près égale on voit un
espace pas grand chose hein B6 tout à
fait normal de la parade d'artémia font
développe la dernière pièce qui n'est
pas sortie on va le fou B7 si les blancs
veulent tenter quelque chose va falloir
faire le 4 ou 5 c'est toujours
affaiblissant donc B3 fou B2 je suppose
et puis pas grand chose voire rien du
tout et noir très confortable
après le 4 ça peut être aussi dans
l'idée de jouer E5 plus tard et ramener
un cavalier un 4 et comment ça joue le
bête E4 fou B7 on va peut-être commencer
à 5 et G4
mais ok c'est un coup responsable
clairement
je vois pas trop comment tu faut
analyser que j'ai quatre Fougères
et sur comme ça je veux faire foi H4 et
je vais protéger mon pur F2 comme ça
petit impôt qui gagne à la cagnotte
c'est cool
j'ai le compte télescope mais
malheureusement je compte c'est quand je
peux pas je découpe d'accord il me dit
que mon pronostic est bien il te dit de
passer en mode théâtre ah oui pardon ah
c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure ça m'a
fait un truc bizarre ok donc je suis en
mode théâtre mais je ne peux toujours
pas je ne peux toujours pas jouer des
coups en fait
donc voilà donc faut B7 est le premier
cookie vient 4 et là il y a fougé 5 à
mon avis parce que E5 est un drame 5 et
G4 ça tourne très très mal pour les
blancs ici
sont développés
il me faut encore des autorisations
tu peux le faire il faut des
autorisations pour pouvoir analyser en
fait de partir en cours
je peux pas le faire avec un compte tu
peux pas le faire donc 5 cavaliers G4
attaque là
et les menaces aussi il faut prendre F3
avec du cavalier prend le 5 parce que
vous voyez en fait
quand même de pousser maintenant
après comment on fait avec les noirs
a des problèmes de temps
ouais mais il joue quand même très bien
mais souvent il a des problèmes de temps
et donc bon contre Magnus faut pas trop
trop salut
je vois rien d'autre pour être honnête
est-ce que je fais est-ce qu'on fait H6
G5 avec les Noirs c'est la question
ouais j'ai quand même très embêtant
c'est comme un peu affaibli après j'ai 5
ans
pour essayer de prendre ce fou
rapidement
il y a beaucoup de préparation mais
c'est toujours pareil vous inquiétez pas
ça va ça rentre dans l'ordre déjà pour
les prochains jours on rappelle
on se retrouve tous les jours pendant 5
jours
de de aujourd'hui à vendredi avec
Stéphane aux manettes tous les jours
de l'accompagner pendant
quasiment la totalité avec
on fait on fait rentrer le coiffeur
mercredi c'est ça Kevin je crois que
c'est mercredi ouais il m'a écrit un
petit message et
je pense parce que moi il m'a dit
mercredi
donc
mercredi bon on l'aime bien
on l'embrasse il nous écoute
le coiffeur breton
donc voilà donc on sera tous les jours à
17h voir à 16h on va essayer de voir
mais ça serait sympa quand même de
pouvoir suivre Maxime on va regarder un
peu les horaires
la division 2 elle qualifie pour la
division 1 de la fois d'après donc elle
est quand même pas on joue pas pour rien
attention division 1 après c'est c'est
quand même la cour des très grands avec
manuscrit Carlson
Fabian
ça joue quand même ça joue fort
globalement
il y a eu 5 hein
il a raison chaise comme fr on voit pas
le temps on va pas le temps mais
pourtant là je suis
ouais salut non mais là c'est c'est un
peu bizarre
donc de toute façon 8,50 pour je vous le
donne pour minuscarsen tandis que
Artémis à 1030 Magnus qui réfléchit à
son cou je suppose qu'il est en train de
réfléchir aux conséquences du coup FG5
et s'il fait pas fouger 5 et bien je
vois pas ce qu'il fait moi perso
peut-être qu'il y aurait peut-être qui
regarde E5 j'ai trop vite sous-estimé
je sais pas cette fois F4 un coup un
coup un peu lambda sur kg 4 on a fout G3
maintenant
donc ce genre de choses je sais pas
intéressant de voir ce qui va décider je
suis assez curieux il a joué au 5 alors
là je on l'a pas vu venir qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur Kiji G4 toujours les
questions
en fait Laurent mais
j'ai un problème encore je peux mettre
le temps désolé non
c'est du 15 + 10 la pendule donc voilà
il y a pas il y a pas d'urgence au temps
15 + 10 + 2 c'était la qualif
heureusement 87 merci
unique tandises qui dit que je dois un
café il y a 20 ans bon ben écoute la
prochaine fois
quand on paye un coup c'est l'heure de
revoir
donc ok j'ai 4 je vois pas je vois pas
je vois pas
le 7
c'est quoi je vais je vais enlever la
vue théâtre parce que en fait 15 + 3
autant pour moi je me suis trompé tu as
raison en plus 15 + 3 la cave c'est le
premier jour bon ça reste quand même ça
reste beaucoup plus
lent que 10 plus de 15 + 3 pardon oui
vous avez raison en plus merci
alors kg 4 a été joué je crois selon mes
selon aussi chass 24 n'hésitez pas à les
sur chaise 24 parce que vous avez non
seulement le temps mais aussi le
stream le stream qui est sur chess 24 on
rappelle
que
ne font plus qu'un dorénavant
donc n'hésitez pas
à vous dire
et
voilà Fuger 5 jouer et là faut prendre
ne marche pas du tout d'après la jauge
Chase 24 vous prend un F3 et pas bon à
cause de fou prends le 7 on arrête pas
de prendre elle a fait on perd du
matériel alors pourquoi je sais pas
exactement et là le seul coup c'est Dame
avait calculé plus loin
c'est tout lui ça
c'est marqué 15 + 3 sur chaise 24 ouais
ça a raison alors non mais c'est marqué
quoi et fouger 5 très bons coups le 5
euh 5 et j'ai 4G 5 en fait très très
bonne ligne d'après d'après l'ordi là je
fais 24 rapidement mais c'était ça pose
des gros problèmes surtout que le seul
coup ici et d'un meute c'est un peu
triché sans faire exprès en voyant les
lignes de l'ordi mais vite seul coup je
sais pas ce que tu en penses mais
c'est pas un coup que je serai pas ravi
de le jouer tu vois
je jouerais vraiment si je pense que
tout le reste est très mauvais
F6 parce que tu en penses aussi
ça va être chaud
[Musique]
il va jouer F6 j'arrive ça va être bon
le temps
bientôt
4 parties c'est ça et ensuite il y a il
y a des bisous des partages au cas où
c'est ça il y a de partout
alors que se passe-t-il d'ailleurs notre
ami notre ami cheesecom fr sur le chat
en cas de 2
donc il va y avoir les départages
sûrement
on n'a pas le stream et le chat en même
temps
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on va manger playmagus et
play Magnus avait mangé 24
il y a beaucoup de gros mangeurs
mais voilà on préfère parler de
de comment de fusion de
synergie
en l'occurrence c'est un peu ça ouais
t'as pas tu as pas complètement tort
mais voilà c'est un type où tout le
monde tout le monde voyait son intérêt
écoute tant mieux si c'est comme ça
et notamment on a ce tournoi ce très
beau tournoi avec plusieurs divisions et
tout ça à mon avis ça aurait pas été
possible de le faire ni sur chaise 24 et
sur chescom tu vois donc c'est quand
même cette fusion a quand même du bon
alors il a joué F6 Artémis il est là il
a pris du cavalier
100 au passage elle est hyper compliquée
cette position je sais pas ce que tu en
penses on peut faire d'un point aussi
sur échec mais ensuite il y a F2 qui
traîne les pièces noires sont très
actives mais ils vont probablement
perdre un pion donc Artémis il a pas
peur
et il donne un pion pour être plus actif
c'est très intéressant ce qui fait
vladys
donc première partie qui normalement
quand Magnus prend la tête dans un match
on le revoit rarement donc elle est
quand même assez importante pour
artemief de se mettre un petit peu en
confiance face aux évidemment grand
favoris du tournoi avec avec icaru
Nakamura
est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire
ici Magnus j'en sais rien je vais mettre
la jauge je paresseux aujourd'hui moi
aussi un peu en deux je rentre debout de
cigale mon cher Stéphane
t'as rien raté
[Rires]
de temps
je t'assure ça sera une perte de temps
le samedi j'ai gagné j'ai gagné le salon
complètement
le problème c'est que j'ai un gros
problème sur ces weekends je suis pas
comme toi parce que toi tu es un
ambitieux tu vois tu gagnes le samedi tu
gagnes le dimanche moi je gagne le
samedi je suis tellement content je me
dis oh là faut pas que je perde le
dimanche
je m'arrange à ce que les chances de
gain de de mes adversaires ce se
réduisent assez rapidement autant que
les miennes aussi vite que les miennes
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc la
partie a pas été passionnante
mais voilà un petit week-end petit
week-end ma foi
raisonnablement sympathique
sans plus
moi moins que le moins moins que le tien
des meilleurs désespoir des chèques
français ouais non
contribué à la montée de ton équipe qui
avait dommage contre Aix-en-Provence et
clairement on le répète en groupe qui
est quand même le groupe le plus très
fort de la haine il y a quand même il y
a les trois premières équipes
honnêtement elle mérite de jouer en Top
16 on va le dire
sur les quatre groupes je pense que tu
je pense que tu mets n'importe quelle
n'importe quelle équipe du podium de
notre groupe dans un autre groupe en
fait elle gagne quoi et c'était trois
équipes vraiment
très très
[Musique]
le niveau est très serré en fait et là
on a tout gagné mais en fait on aurait
pu perdre de match on aurait pu
[Musique]
donc Agen Aix-en-Provence et les trois
autres montés donc il y a quatre groupes
comme tu le disais mais on voit avec
tout le respect du haut aux équipes
Cergy-Pontoise le club 6008 et la Spar
Medoc alors ça c'est nos amis de
bordelais à côté de naujacs
ah j'ai pas vu
le problème c'est que votre groupe est
tellement palpitant de groupe donc voilà
en fait je suis un petit peu mais voilà
donc je connais les trois autres équipes
qui montent bravo bravo à elle
évidemment mais c'est vrai que si on
mettait une des trois équipes dans le
groupe Sud ça serait chaud quand même
derrière qui qui est très très chaud
parce que l'équipe 2 de grâce
en Top 16 donc
voilà mais bon bravo à Cannes qui a
quand même non non une histoire une
vraie histoire de la formation et on
voit que c'est que des jeunes du club
quasiment tous non quand tu vois quand
tu vois Gary Guillaume et tu as un
Timothée Raja Benjamin
je me suis dit le seul qui était pas tu
as été formé à Cannes aussi non à Nice
c'était pas calme mais
j'ai été j'ai été formé à Nice et après
j'ai travaillé en tant qu'entraîneur à
Cannes donc peut-être le seul le seul
qui a moins de liens entre guillemets
c'est Benoît Lepeltier
ça reste quand même super impressionnant
et et belle équipe Canoas avec des
matchs des beaux matchs je suis déçu
pour mes amis d'agence je les embrasse
et je leur souhaite
de se remettre bien vite et ils vont ils
vont gagner l'année prochaine allez
ouais non mais c'est clair
qui est exprès pour nous casser les
pieds on a toujours une
là qui
paye des joueurs pour pour ce qui est
normal tu vois
mais tu vois c'est dur parce qu'on a une
bonne équipe depuis toujours mais il y a
toujours un
il y a toujours une année ou attends en
fait on est abonné au deuxième place je
pense qu'on arrive on a fait deuxième
peut-être quasiment
un truc de fou et
et ouais on en entend comme blues et le
Top 12 et après on est vite
plus facile entre guillemets de se
maintenir surtout que
donc ouais non voilà moi regarde les
trois autres qualifiés alors moi tu veux
moi je pensais que je l'ai dit avant le
match contre Agen je pense que c'est vu
le niveau des équipes actuelles c'est
plus facile peut-être de se maintenir en
Top 16 que de monter en Top 12 enfin
dans le groupe qu'on avait en fait
que les deux qui sont passés
et ex qui passe pas il a quand même
enfin je pense plus fort que beaucoup
d'équipes qui sont comme ça
beaucoup euh
l'année dernière
mais
certaines mais bon c'est vrai que je
pense que tu as raison parce que cette
obligation de victoire permanente et
d'un côté plus dur je pense
avec ça salut salut Fatou salut Patou
salut
salut et donc attends on va voir la
partie de manus parce que là c'est avec
Magnus un petit peu en difficulté je
sais pas ce que tu en penses mais avec
simplement trois minutes contre ah ils
ont 3 minutes chacun tu me diras
et du cavalier 2 et c'est chaud c'est ça
même un dernier place tu auras 8 quelque
chose comme ça
c'est chaud mais là c'est plutôt bon
mardi c'est qu'il a quand même pris un
pion donc maintenant il faut assumer
mais
je trouve que c'est une position plus
facile à faire pour le coup
regarde toutes les pièces noires à part
la tour à 8 qu'on peut faire jouer à un
coup toutes les pièces sont quasi sur
leur case optimale et on voit c'est fou
qui rayonne sur le sur le rock blanc
alors évidemment ça serait encore mieux
avec les dames mais ça semble être assez
largement assez compensation pour le
pion qui manque après faut pas se rater
c'est toujours un pion
donc bon il veut récupérer son pion
Artémis c'est pas crédit comment
qu'est-ce qu'il a vu là c'était une
décision très très responsable
je crois que j'ai eu les droits
on a les droits toujours pas
pour pas cher
[Rires]
j'ai dû le voir au moins 18 fois dans ma
vie
faut prendre F3 puis on prend il a joué
un fouet 3 ou pas c'est la partie
c'est la partie
ok donc moi j'ai deux qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire
artemief à priori l'idée ça serait de
faire cavalier H5 ou un truc comme ça
pour attaquer mais il y a fou des seins
que j'ai l'impression
pour attaquer F3 tu vois et c'est de
récupérer F3 à un moment ou un autre
c'est la solidité de ce truc là parce
que ou alors H6 ici mais H6 je vois pas
trop à quoi ça peut être considéré
ça peut être une idée intéressante tout
à fait est-ce que j'ai utilisé après à
base de cavalières H5 et cavaliers
[Musique]
est-ce que je fais non je peux toujours
pas jouer
c'est ça
oui pour ceux qui a été pas rendu compte
mais poisson d'avril très réussi de la
part de chaise comme avec Annie Giri qui
fait cette vidéo c'était génial
c'est très très réussi
[Musique]
très très bien vu
alors
pour F5 ok il a fait trois huit fois F5
et là qu'est-ce qu'il y a et regarder
toujours le même problème 40 secondes
alors il est très rapide en blitz et
attention
à la pendule donc tu peux gaffer en fait
tu as qu'à le maillot de Carlson c'est
pas n'importe qui
d'ailleurs en parlant de rebondir sur le
fait que Manu ce qu'il a pu être le
champion du monde très très bientôt
Laurent
est-ce que pour toi le match il a
intérêt
s non je vais suivre rien que par
curiosité de tu vois j'ai eu la chance
le grand privilège de participer au 5
matchs de Magnus donc déjà rien de
regarder un match champion du monde d'un
point de vue extérieur sans avoir le
stress du résultat ça doit rien du tout
déjà je pense que ça va être un plaisir
assez finalement unique que j'ai pas eu
depuis 10 ans et rien que par aussi par
curiosité de quelles ouvertures ils vont
choisir et pourquoi et tout ça rien que
ça
rien que ça ça m'intéresse énormément et
ensuite moi j'espère que tu sais quand
on est pas parti prendre on espère voir
du spectacle et du beau jeu et une
victoire de Ding moi je suis pour je
suis team Ding voilà je suis ok moi
aussi c'était pour dire moi aussi
c'était pour dîner à la base
et ce joueur j'adore
magnifique on peut bouger les pièces
c'est magique on va y arriver on a eu
les droits alors attends il a joué
cavalier 5 fougères 6 donc c'est une
proposition de nul implicite de la part
de Madison
propose de répéter les coûts
et on va voir en tout cas ce qui va se
passer mais en tout cas d'un point de
vue rien que les ouvertures et le choix
les ouvertures et le choix psychologique
de chacun parce qu'à mon avis n'est pas
fait des grosses erreurs sur son
précédent match il y avait aucune
surprise dans ses choix en fait on avait
pas ce qu'on soit spécialement plus
intelligent mais c'est juste que il a
décidé de jouer classique de jouer ce à
quoi sont entendus c'est à dire des
Espagnols assez molles avec les noirs
des pétroles et des Catalans archi
solides bon on s'attendait à ça en fait
si tu nous demandais de de deviner un
truc c'était ça donc je trouvais qu'il y
avait moins pas assez de
passer de prise de risque et pas assez
de d'éléments de surprise tu vois dans
ses choix alors je suis curieux de voir
s'il va s'en tenir au cahier tu sais
l'école limite entre guillemets
soviétique tu vois on joue classique on
joue bien aux échecs comme ça ou si il
va mettre un peu plus de surprise dans
son truc bon moi je navigue clair sur le
sur ce qui devrait faire est-ce que
c'est ce qui va faire ou pas pour
l'instant les joueurs russes tu sais
entre caryaki et nepomiyashi ils ont eu
tous les deux la même stratégie de match
avec le même entraîneur podkin tu vois
pas de skin qui est un peu arcade très
bon entraîneur mais qui est qui a ce
truc de pas pas les pousser à surprendre
ce qui est un peu étonnant à mon avis
[Musique]
qui est quasiment rien
puis dans ils ont joué sur un rythme de
sénateur depuis le début
il est pas content du tout j'aime pas du
tout alors la jauge Mégal mais
franchement
je pense que c'est hyper dur à jouer
peut-être qu'il y a un truc pour faire
nul mais
il a l'air complètement
la jupe ah il a mangé comme ça ok
apparemment c'était la seule chance de
faire nul bravo il l'a trouvé ouais mais
c'est
signal que j'aurais bien perdu hein
tomber
ok il prend un jeu il marche comme tous
les pions mais
c'est dur
je risque de perdre encore un pion une
option qui avance donc
tour contre cavalier fou ah
[Musique]
alors qu'il avait fermé là il râle
si si défendez pas
c'était chaud est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
parties
mais bon
du coup j'ai pas les caméras je vais
passer sur le sur l'autre chaîne
hop là
mon avis il est mal mais
tout à l'heure j'avais un bug avec ça en
fait au niveau des caméras
est-ce que je suis le seul à voir mal le
temps
de non mais c'est pourquoi en fait on
voit mal le temps
parce qu'en fait sur la vue que j'ai et
ben derrière il y a les logos de la
Process ligue 3
d'ailleurs je pense tu vois derrière la
photo de
CF il y a il y a un logo il y a aussi le
logo derrière
et
donc du coup c'est
c'est la vue qui me qui me fait tout
bugger
alors comment ça marche cette histoire
qui est mieux et pourquoi les blancs les
noirs ont l'air pas mal avec un pion à
trois là ça peut foncer on peut avoir
une des que des surprises dans cette
première onde ça serait énorme est-ce
qu'il y a pas des vidéos même avec tout
reprendre B2 les dames chercher
évidemment
peut-être qu'il faut faire ça on est
rendu à ça mais c'est ça qui est assez
blanc donc il faut qu'il se dépêche
quand on a que moi est-ce qu'il va pas
perdre le pion le 5 la faut prendre 5
non
et d'un prince C4 tous ces change ça va
faire nul
et oui ça va faire nul tout ça pour ça
mais grosse partie apparemment entre les
carreaux Nakamura et
[Musique]
ça va faire mieux est-ce que Fabienne
okonna a terminé
il est gagnant car wanna apparemment il
a une finale de cavalier où il vient de
gaffe je l'ai poussé là bien comme il
faut
contre le gang
et quand il se qui un diable sur
internet très très fort
est-ce que ça gaze c'est toujours la
limite c'est final de cavalier c'est que
du calcul clairement
qui est et on sait qu'en division 2 on a
on a mvl mais il était à 2-0 contre
Alexia DELF donc il perd pas de temps il
perd pas de temps Maxime va chez La
Grave on ira voir la pause
ce qu'il a fait dans sa troisième partie
donc là est-ce que c'est comment ça
c'est nul oui c'est mieux
[Musique]
de te faire une fourchette
ouais mais le problème c'est que tu peux
pas vraiment me dominer le cavalier non
apparemment
il se défendre mais
effectivement attention B5 c'est pas bon
il y a que ces trois cavaliers A4 alors
le cavalier dominé
5 encore calculer ça cavalier 3 échecs
[Musique]
de Fabien on peut la montrer peut-être
roller
elle déconne complètement
je sais pas ça
complètement terminé 3 moi aussi
j'ai chacun intermédiaire cavalier
36 j'ai simplement
donc tu fais attends
c'est fini
incroyable
c'est même étonnant parce que bon je
pense que même le message a pu trouver
[Musique]
donc nul Nakamura est-ce qu'on a un
tableau récap ou pas alors
après ça c'est l'autre l'autre tableau
juste voir ce qu'il a fait
j'ai pas de plat alors
on va vous donner les résultats de toute
façon
donc juste pour vous sachiez mvl et
qualifié 2 et demi un demi
donc il va affronter au deuxième tour
quand je veux dire qui va contre le
deuxième tour il affrontera le vainqueur
de cramenic et youngui qui pour
l'instant sont à 1,5
et dans la division 1 donc comme on
l'avait vu on a
pas de puceau Artémis
avec carwana contre l'icône et fais de
CF contre Nakamura donc donc voilà
Laurent on va faire une petite pause
et
réglé de toute façon
j'ai des publicités
[Musique]
attends 30 secondes
et j'ai le boîtier chez moi il permet de
mesurer la qualité de l'air et si vous
avez du radon chez vous
le taux de CO2 aussi enfin et le taux
d'humidité aussi donc ça vous permet en
fait de mesurer la qualité de l'air chez
vous et donc c'est très utile si vous
avez du radon chez vous vous partez en
courant faut absolument faire quelque
chose donc voilà donc c'est quelque
chose qui permet de mesurer la qualité
de l'air et évidemment dans un
environnement sain on travaille mieux si
l'air n'est pas bon on les neurones ne
marchent moins bien évidemment alors pas
de il faut savoir que ce tournoi et ben
il est exporté par plusieurs bah il y a
plusieurs
[Musique]
Sims Puma etc on va vous montrer un
petit peu tout ça donc on va vous mettre
un peu la pub donc on doit faire
aujourd'hui trois pauses pour vous
montrer à chaque pause de deux de nos
partenaires lors de cet événement donc
c'est pour ça que les pauvres sont
obligatoires donc on va partir dessus et
on se revoit ici ben c'est 50 minutes
Laurent
à tout de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Laurent
pour cette deuxième partie de la
revanche avec P12 contre Magnus qui
vient de perdre sa première partie
donc avec les Blancs
sublime style position il l'a dit Magnus
Carson de la part d'artémie donc très
très gros client il était mal au temps
mais comme d'habitude mal au temps il
joue quand même des bons coups et salut
à tous qui nous rejoignent dans le chat
robbinside notre cher ami homme homme a
tout faire ici c'est ce qu'on c'est ce
qu'on va dire et voilà tu as encore des
félicitations donc Fatou aussi qui est
monté c'était la fin des nationales on
rappelle pour ceux qui nous attaquent
tous montés
de N2 à N1
robinside avec aussi
[Rires]
allez au revoir petite pression lors de
ce match
contre les je leur pose normalement
contre les enfin bon on verra
[Musique]
je me déplace pas
bon on verra tout ça l'année prochaine
en tout cas bravo ça fait plaisir parce
que c'est la famille Armas évidemment
qui a lancé ce club c'est on arrête si
si
j'ai faux mais je pense que c'est
vraiment le club de l'ancien camping à
noges-sur-mer le camping échec où j'ai
même fait un stage de l'équipe de France
là-bas ils sont ils sont très
sympathiques les Hamas donc on leur
passe salut amical s'ils sont là j'ai vu
que Julius jouait en jouer dans l'équipe
ça fait plaisir ça fait un moment que
j'ai pas vu et voilà c'est mérité ça
fait plaisir d'avoir tous beau monde en
Top 16 l'année prochaine alors on a un
double fiancetto et bien écoute Artémis
il est fidèle à lui-même ça joue ça joue
c'est rien
alors le principe du tournoi alors à
Rania
alors il y a trois poules pour 1 2 3
alors en fait à la fin donc c'est pas
exactement quand mais je crois qu'il y a
5 tournois comme ça et non non pardon il
y a 6 tournois comme ça je crois bien 6
6 ouais c'est ça 6 et en fait le
vainqueur du groupe 1
il y a il va avoir en fait une place si
vous voulez pour
les deux premiers les deux les deux
premiers bah oui parce que Magnus et
Naka était qualifié ils avaient fait la
finale du précédent donc ils étaient
ok bon moi ce qu'on m'a dit c'était que
le premier qualifié pour la finale et
qu'à la fin pour combler les places qui
manquaient et ben il y avait des points
en fait je sais que dans chaque tournoi
tu peux gagner des points je sois dans
le tournoi dans le dans le tournoi enfin
dans la poule A B ou C il y a un tableau
avec des points par exemple quand tu
gagnes la poule A tu gagnes 150 points
mais en fait on s'en fout et par exemple
quand tu gagnes là pour le 2 je crois
que tu gagnes 50 points je crois voilà
donc c'est le leader du groupe de leader
du du
circuit en fait et en fait les deux
premiers étaient qualifiés pour ce pour
ce deuxième tournoi parce que il y a eu
un seul tournoi avant et donc voilà les
leaders étaient les deux premiers ok ça
ça a beaucoup de sens donc du coup voilà
il y a pas mal de temps comme ça et à
chaque fois en fait chaque tournoi pour
se qualifier et ben il y a les tournois
que d'ailleurs on a fait un Laurent
tournois qualificatif il y a quelques
donc tu en as très très costaud où il y
a enfin le niveau est absolument
incroyable et pour se qualifier bah il
faut il faut pas tailler Laurent n'a pas
réussi à se qualifier c'est-à-dire un
petit peu le niveau du tournoi
et
me qualifier pour la division 3
mais ouais non effectivement c'est très
chaud et donc je pense qu'elle est deux
il y a les deux il y a le vainqueur de
la division 2 ça c'est sûr il va en
Division 1 et ensuite ouais il reste 5
places à octroyer dans ce toit de calife
pour être dans les 8 premiers après une
division de division 3 et une division 2
Stéphane on retrouve Maxime machagrave
qui a gagné son premier match contre
Alex et qui joue on va peut-être demain
va chez l'agraphe cramique on va chez
agrafe cramique je crois qu'on on va
être obligé de prendre l'antenne enfin
être obligé d'être très content de
prendre l'antenne une heure plus tôt
pour suivre ça parce que c'est quand
même très sympa évidemment Vladimir
cramique pour ceux qui ne le connaissent
pas ancien champion du monde
qui a détrôné l'ogre de bas coût le
celui qui est considéré par beaucoup
c'est pas par toi aussi Stéphane comme
le meilleur joueur de tous les temps
Gary Kasparov en 2000 en 2000 avec ce
fameux mur de Berlin qui
on a toujours pas été détruit voilà donc
Vladimir cramique légende du jeu qui a
pris sa retraite mais qui revient sur
ces tournois online donc une partie
contre Maxime ça sera ça sera très
simple
enfin un match contre Maxime ça sera
vraiment un truc un truc absolument
match
mais il y avait une coupe du monde ouais
c'est ça
coupe du monde à 30 et d'ailleurs
j'avais joué cette coupe du monde mais
j'étais parti quand ils ont joué j'étais
parti depuis deux semaines deux bonnes
semaines
c'est un peu bizarre en fait tu vois des
voix des joueurs joués dans un tournoi
et tu dis ah ben oui je joue aussi mais
effectivement
Maxime qui est très très fort hein c'est
format mais Vladimir avait gagné cette
Coupe du monde en 2013 en battant Maxime
et en demi-finale et André Keane en
finale je me souviens d'une partie
d'ailleurs de Maxime il avait tenu
une finale nulle c'était il avait
peut-être deux ou trois points de moins
c'était un truc de fou et
[Musique]
ce petit ce mot de Magnus Carlsen
l'école française de la souffrance voilà
il prend une c'est vrai qu'il aille
fierté particulière mais Maxime à tenir
des finales parfois très très difficile
ou beaucoup d'entre nous je dirais bon
ben c'est foutu je cherche plus
comme un lion
donc voilà ça sera évidemment très très
sympa à regarder si attention cramique
il jouait youngui il y avait il y avait
un et demi partout attention
on aimerait avacher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en plus maxime a travaillé quelques
temps avec lui
il se connaissent très bien
oh [__] c'est un joueur qui est plus
dans le circuit mais c'est une grande
légende champion du monde ok
ça fait plaisir de voir comme ça
franchement
sans sans se suicider je pense qu'il va
il va essayer de rendre de mettre un peu
de peps dans cette position si c'est
possible mais alors
c'est pas très engageant comme position
je sais pas ce que tu en penses
une partie tranquille
[Musique]
positionnel et
puis bon il a un point d'avance donc
ce qui est étonnant c'est que il prend
il prend du temps quand même il prend
beaucoup de temps 5 minutes alors qu'il
joue des doubles sur keto très
régulièrement là on peut imaginer
cavaliero 5 quelque chose comme ça
voilà alors pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent bonjour à d'autres people qui
est qui nous a rejoint aussi j'avais pas
vu et
voilà
on rappelle c'est 1-0 c'est après avoir
après la première partie pardon 1-0 pour
vladys
donc faut absolument que Magnus marque
deux points sur les trois prochaines
parties s'il veut continuer ce match au
minimum donc avec deux noirs c'est pas
c'est pas évident
on va voir alors en parlant de furosa
bon je pense pas pouvoir convertir dans
la mode mais c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose que que
il aime bien c'est une autre façon quoi
et du coup bah il fait ça aussi mais
c'est pas une reconversion non plus quoi
alors pour ceux qui sont inquiets pour
aller résa il est dans le grand donc il
joue tous les trois du grand c'est un
joueur régulier comme on dit de la
saison régulière donc il y a beaucoup de
tournoi ensuite il est annoncé à
norrichesses donc il joue dans richesse
hier à la Coupe du monde en juillet donc
c'est quelqu'un qui va quand même
investir pas mal de temps aux échecs il
va jouer 4 ou 5 tournois là dans les
dans les dans les trois prochains mois
il est par période il sait qu'il fait
des breaks et après il joue beaucoup
donc c'est un peu comme ça que ça marche
peut-être le temps de de recharger les
batteries de retrouver la motivation et
ce genre de choses je sais pas si tu as
vu ce qu'il a fait dans le playing non
c'est pas du tout vu t'as pas vu ce
qu'il a fait dans Le Play là j'adore
cette histoire donc on va compter
elle est énorme donc allez Zafir rouge à
avait le score de 5 sur 8 avant la
dernière partie ok figure-toi que pour
être qualifié en Division 1 il faut au
minimum si c'est demi sur 9 donc ça
c'était pas possible par contre 5 sur 8
cette qualifie celle sur 9 cette
qualifie minimum pour la division 3 si
tu gagnes tu es en division 2 si tu fais
nul c'est pas clair c'est une histoire
de partage qu'est-ce qu'il a fait à lire
les infos il a quitté le tournoi c'est
la division 1 ou rien il a simplement
quitté le tournoi avec ces 5 et demi sur
8 donc tu arrêtes donc tu es passes tu
es pas classifié tu es pas dans le
classement
qui n'est pas la première et il préfère
ne pas jouer que jouer
dans les deux ou trois quoi
c'est quand même quelque chose c'est
division
alors ça dure longtemps là
je sors pas d'excuses mais et puis
c'est pas facile
on a vu les joueurs qui avait il y a mvl
il y a kravnik il y a abdos
la division
2 et division 3 elle est pas facile non
plus je sais pas évidemment on n'est pas
allé chercher aussi loin on peut pas
suivre tout mais clairement ouais
c'est le plus fort et après il y a pas
mal de joueurs du genre petshot et
tourisme
[Musique]
alors on a une question échec alors on
va prendre une question échec on a le
fou en V2 on nous demande si avec le
pion des quatre il est pas terrible mais
oui mais il faut mettre les pions au
centre et le four en B2 alors
effectivement il est pas mal placé il
est pas si bien placé parce que
effectivement la diagonale est fermée
mais on déjà en dissuade un potentiel
c'est 5 parce que ça ça ouvrirait la
grande diagonale peut-être que ça va
arriver quand même et on voit pas trop
de rupture pour les Noirs si on fait
passer cette C5 donc il y a pas trop de
plan en fait si on fait passer ça donc
il est quand même pas si mal placé et
voilà ça a été joué donc c'est probable
que soit puis on prend ses 5 soit on va
laisser faire puis on prend des quatre
et à ce moment-là ce fou va jouer c'est
aussi connecté avec l'ensemble de la
structure qui fait que c'est cette C5
finalement et la seule rupture pour les
noirs et donc va très probablement
arriver il est noir veulent faire un
plan actif
donc en gros on sait 5 on peut manger du
cavalier ou du pion mais par rapport à
la structure en fait si description on
va voir une structure ici également
pendant
cette structure en fait
qui sont ouverts
de soutien à trois pièces et qui peuvent
pousser à n'importe quel moment et on se
dit c'est très dynamique c'est très très
dynamique et c'est exactement ce que
manus veut et regardez il a 12 minutes
contre 5 oui il fait pas ça au hasard
non plus il a attendu de faire ses cinq
au moment où déjà Artémis un petit sujet
avec le temps alors pas très gros sujet
on sait ça rapidité mais quand même
il faut prendre des il faut prendre des
décisions est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ici avec les Blancs moi ça me
semble pas évident est-ce que des 4e
menaces par exemple est-ce qu'on doit
vis-à-vis déjà ouais non c'est pas très
agréable et il fait cavalier
sur des quatre quand même
intéressant intéressant est-ce qu'on
peut faire des 4 quand même est-ce qu'on
peut faire on peut envisager à ces
quatre je pense ça serait mauvais ça
donnerait la case des quatre ça semble
trop ambitieux C5 C4 pour les Noirs
alors comment on fait du coup est-ce
qu'on recycle ce cavalier
là OK
mais est-ce que mes pions vont être
faibles aussi et ça coûte pas forcément
le couplement fou je dépends plus trop
le passé simple cavalier ici quand même
il est combien ici puis il est au centre
il est mieux aussi simple je suis
d'accord avec toi Emmanuel temps de
faire ce genre de chose c'est toujours
la question est-ce que sur kissc7 je
vais pas faire un coup de Cavalière 4 et
tu vois elle est très complexe cette
position parce que finalement il y a il
y a deux paires de pions échanger donc
il reste quand même à peu près tout des
pieds sur l'échiquier très très
compliqué
c'est compliqué à prendre comme décision
quand même pour pouvoir
[Musique]
prendre une décision aussi
de côté
il y a Jacques gars attention je suis je
suis modérateur c'est le Nick bolity je
sais pas qui c'est nickel c'est ça le
problème
c'est pas ça doit être génial
[Musique]
parce que dimanche
je sens que c'est un entraîneur de
tennis un peu obscur tu sais tu sais un
sort de
je sais pas mais ouais c'est ça
commence bien
et enfin entraîneur de tennis américain
père personnalité influente du vent du
tennis il est mort de l'international
tennis ça va tu es pardonné
regarde ça me va
ok donc
on a une question de ciel bleu et de
commentateur pour Chelsea et pour le
tournoi des candidats féminins me
centrer alors si elle peut jouer te
répondre en tant que chaise anciences 24
je vais te dire quelque chose qui est
malheureusement la réalité déjà le chess
evil masters et un tournoi de la maison
c'est-à-dire c'est la maison qui
organise donc déjà bon ben c'est un
tournoi évidemment qu'on prend beaucoup
plus au sérieux et malheureusement
malheureusement
le les échecs féminins j'avais fait la
mer expérience parce que j'ai essayé de
retransmettre ça il y a beaucoup moins
de vues
que pour un tu auras des candidats
normales c'est de 1 à 10 les proportions
donc c'est pas qu'on fasse de
[Musique]
mais il y a un moment où il faut aussi
je regarde pas
streamer non plus quoi donc c'est un peu
plus puis là il faut avouer que les
candidats féminins elles sont ça manque
de d'histoire tu vois de trucs là c'est
entre deux chinoises pour jouer une
autre chinoises tu vois ça manque un
petit peu de
candidats féminin entre judither et
ouifane et je peux te dire qu'avec tout
on serait pas en train de commenter ça
on sera en train de commenter le match
Olga où il fan voilà c'est toujours
pareil
il y a quand même du il y a des grosses
personnalités donc je crois que c'est
plus une question de ça de de
même par rapport même par rapport tu
vois là maintenant on est en train de
voir que internet exploser tu vois avec
avec bon bah tous les streams tous les
réseaux et c'est vrai que là avant les
deux chinoises qui en fait sont
inconnues pour le pour le monde des
échecs même moi je sais donc voilà alors
que
si tu vois un championnat du monde alors
je dis au hasard je dis je sais pas
bottes contre
cramling bah écoute il y aura beaucoup
plus de vues non mais c'est la vérité
mais déjà mais je pense je sais pas si
ça au hasard mais elle joue avec quoi
tous les streamers qui sont là-bas
ouais mais il y a beaucoup plus de vues
que que la même plus de vues là que que
les pommes de terre
reste ça reste mais t'imagines qu'on est
quand même en train de d'essayer de
comparer ça quoi alors d'un point de vue
chacun
ça va absolument rien à voir mais en
fait là ce que les gens recherchent j'ai
l'impression hein c'est plus les tu vois
ben le le réseau et le fait de de
aussi aider et ça manque de ça manque de
personnalité marquante je dirais en ce
moment
quand même elle était vachement suivie
où il fane aussi malheureusement elle a
arrêté et donc voilà ça manque de truc
tu vois de
je trouve mais vraiment c'était dommage
c'est exactement ça à venir ça va venir
certainement
moi j'attends le petit match
c'est une bonne pub mais le petit match
des casaques avec impatience ah d'accord
je dois avoir l'arrière
par exemple tu vois on sent qu'elle a
moi j'ai joué contre elle au Cap d'Agde
tu vois que tu sens que elle a une
personnalité tu vois une vraie
personnalité elle peut être je pense
après je suis pas non plus expert mais
je pense qu'elle est elle peut être très
intéressante pour le pour le grand
public et énormément attention à 18 ans
et champion du monde de Blitz douche
champion du monde de blé ça joue fort
donc elle peut être vraiment une des
meilleures choses au monde à pas elle se
déteste cordialement avec sa compatriote
abdom
et salut à Yoshua
et oui je prévois de cuisiner du porche
pour Marie en fait je sais pas mais
c'était absolument délire et c'était des
oiseaux
c'était c'était une engueulade de
collégien quoi c'était euh
une petite page de pub pour notre ami
yosh
Iglesias qui m'a d'ailleurs battu à
cette tristement j'avais envie de dire
le match
[Musique]
pour résumer un peu le match parce que
on a fait trois cadences en 5 + 1 j'ai
perdu trois et demi je crois
que la section Bullet tu allais
ben yacha non mais après
un incrément
[Musique]
c'est sûr mais en fait il y a aussi un
truc je sais pas si tu as vu mais
souvent dans les dans les speechess et
ben souvent le joueur que tu qualifies
comme être moins fort que l'autre en
Bullet souvent c'est lui qui fait la
surprise moi j'avais vu mais tu avais vu
Caravana complètement hot playmvl tu
avais vu des trucs comme ça quoi en fait
en Bullet quoi tu dis mais attends mais
et en fait voilà mais bon non mais Yoha
ambulette
j'ai personne qui ne croyait pas en toi
sur ce match non mais en plus vous voyez
parce que ouais parce que tu vas l'air
tu m'as l'air vite c'est beaucoup quand
même donc voilà je me suis dit en plus
c'était genre ah oui mais bon non mais
il va m'éclater il est plus fort que moi
et je me dis mais arrête et en fait bah
j'ai perdu tu es sûr quoi en fait il
fallait un petit peu il faut me parler
comme ça des yeux pour que je me relâche
un peu tu vois il faut parler comme ça
en vrai je pense perçu non parce qu'en
fait si tu veux on avait pas établi on
n'avait pas exactement on a commencé le
match sans savoir comment passer le
match parce qu'on savait pas si c'était
les termes de points comme au
speechestre ou si on faisait un truc de
7 et moi je préférais faire les têtes là
vas-y c'est pas mal et en fait comme
comme elle a gagné 3 et demi deux et
demi je crois premier 7 et que le
deuxième c'est que j'ai gagné quatre et
demi
et du coup troisième set je gagne 2 et
demi à 0 et demi vu le temps qui reste
qui reste de partie bon bah je perds les
deux ça fait égalité du coup ça fait un
c'était une ligne j'ai rien et des
partages je prends des euros en fait
j'ai perdu les quatre dernières
partition en Bullet pour perdre le match
ah d'accord ouais mais alors que si on a
fait du score je regardais mais comme on
n'avait pas dit et comment puis-je
l'avais dit que je préférais faire en 7
je me suis dit on va tu vois donc dans
le doute on a joué des partages j'ai
perdu d'ailleurs je te dois les Seb mais
quand je te verrais connecter on a parié
des subs
et donc je suis dans quelques saveurs
mais il faut que je faut que je la vois
connecté
ouais donc on va on va revenir aux
échecs bon oui c'est vrai de 1 à 10 pour
candidate à un tournoi du top ouais
clairement et c'est vrai qu'il y a
Alexandra Costa new que qui fait du bien
aux échecs féminins ça c'est vrai mais
bon malheureusement je remarque elle
s'est qualifiée pour les pour les
candidates là elle sait pas elle sait
pas elle sait pas qualifier voilà pour
pour les matchs pour la finale mais
effectivement ouais des choses comme
Alexandra costinio alors
on va regarder la partie de Magnus une
25 contre 6,50 je crois que c'est le
principal élément et comme tu l'as dit
tout à l'heure c'est pions pendant
qu'ils sont toujours là
s'échangent plus les pions deviennent
faibles normalement mais effectivement
plus compliqué que ça les échecs un
moment donné on risque d'avoir un un
petit décapeur si je prends E2 tu
reprends le 2 et je fais des quatre ça
marche parce que tout en prise en C1
la tour est pas les plus elle pue en
donc est-ce que c'est bon j'en sais rien
quand je fous B2
pas parce que si je prends mes deux au
pire des cas il y a tout reprend les B3
et
la paire de fou qui s'active le cavalier
qui a une case en 4 et ça c'est juste
complètement dramatique
donc sur des 4 on va juste même si je
bouge le fou quand même moins grave j'ai
envie de dire
pense parce que c'est les pions avancent
par exemple tu vois il est moins en fait
les colonnes sont pas ouvertes à côté
donc par exemple le pion c'est 5 il peut
il peut devenir plus tard
[Musique]
il y a des deux donc
il a joué il a il a mangé il a joué à 4
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est toujours toujours la petite
précision de tout est le diable est dans
les détails mais voilà Magnus Carcen est
un diable c'est sûr peu de temps la
pendule là pour pour
plus que peur est-ce que je peux faire
je peux tenter un X 5 intermédiaires
que je peux tenter ça
parce que tu serais tenté de donner la
qualité mais il y aura un problème sur
ces 5
donc je sais pas
on va peut-être
on l'a pas dit mais oui ah oui c'est
vrai parce que c'est pour qu'on l'a pas
dit
parce qu'on l'a pas vu
parce que tu l'aurais dit tu es pas
timide
mais non j'ai pas vu
[Musique]
attention chest photopon la vie les gens
qui posent pour la première fois qu'il
dit bonjour se trouve la fresque
attention on va pas être pote non plus
alors
là j'aime beaucoup les Noirs quand même
[Musique]
C4 cayd4 tu vois je peux je peux revenir
il faut pas que je te laisse bloquer
évidemment si je fais ces quatre il peut
y avoir un truc comme ça il y a un
problème aussi sur mes pions un jour sur
le long terme mais j'ai pas de laisser
bloqué je pense sur le long terme là il
y a toujours un prix donc je peux pas
faire vite malheureusement ça aurait
peut-être pas mal regarde le désastre le
désastre à la pendule quand même 14
secondes
prise et en fait il va ouvrir la colonne
pas grand-chose
mais c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
il va essayer tout liquider pour faire
nul est-ce que Foussais si c'est un coup
ou pas je vais manger à 4 pour enlever
la tour
que tu voulais faire j'imagine
t'as pas le temps de manger
[Musique]
c'est pas bon du tout
intéressant avec F4 je reviens
même des coups d'abord moi je clou un
tour simple
t'as pas de façon adéquate
on va le défendre les pièces sont très
très mal coordonnées à se détroit est
fou ces trois aussi
c'est fini c'est juste perdu donc il
prend content il va punir les choses
proprement alors my pseudo qui nous dit
quelqu'un pourrait filer une
augmentation avec ses épées il est
obligé de vivre dans une caravane de toi
et dans un chalet dans les Alpes
donc il est pas mal il est pas mal
manuscrit Arsène là il est il est il est
au confort vous inquiétez pas pour lui
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu ces déco
très bon je trouve ça au contraire ça
fait chalet quoi moi j'aime bien
bois comme ça je trouve ça trop classe
quoi normalement il va dans les endroits
plutôt cosy hein
quelques fois on descend pas il est
sympa au formule
pas de pas trop pour lui
tour c'est un menace D3 et fou C3
ils vont pêcher ça un jour enlever la
visite
si je pense que ça va être
ça va être plus compliqué vous seul
casse légale c'est E2 pour la tour je
crois pour protéger ce cavalier et
ensuite on va on va faire
c'est parce qu'on va faire mais ça sent
tellement gagnant
toi tu fais quoi
j'ai le plus direct qui doit être en
train de calculer aussi c'est d4d3 comme
tu avais parlé tout à l'heure suivie de
fou C3 créer une menace tu peux pas
prendre des trois parce que ton foin F1
est cloué c'était de découvrir par roi
G2 je te fais un fousser 6 qui serait
cruel
je peux pas manger des cavaliers donc
sur des cartes
en fait c'est terminé ça ça
va être terminé de penser deux minutes
entre 6 secondes
il va être de bonne humeur
je te le dire parce que là franchement
c'est inratable non
je sais pas il réfléchit attention tout
droit
là qui va tomber il va être obligé de
donner la qualité Vlad Artémis
et tu reprends des trois ah ça se bat un
petit peu en marque
ça se barre
comme ça quoi
[Musique]
on va aller voir Wesley sauf à ça les
vannes à rognan ouais c'est chaud je
crois qu'il est en train de gagner il y
a une île entre Karona et le Kang donc
ça fait on a deux matchs on a on va voir
peut-être les quatre matchs là
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas
il est jeune lui il parle de Méribel 98
effectivement mais elle 98 un national
un champion de France qui s'est déroulé
là-bas pour les amoureux de la montagne
on rappelle c'est fun je sais pas si
tira ça t'arrive d'aller au championnat
de France là c'est la montagne on parle
de montagne franchement franchement pour
une fois qu'il y a un cadre qui ça
m'intéresse pas mais bon après je peux
la France que ça veut dire non
tu sais que moi je pense le dernier open
que j'ai fait en France ça remonte ça
remonte beaucoup parce que je me dis bah
à petit à partir j'aimerais partir loin
en fait et donc je vais souvent en
Espagne d'ailleurs pour jouer l'Alpe
d'Huez
là franchement
tu vois si c'est pour aller dans une
salle genre un gymnase ou un truc comme
ça ou bon ça m'intéresse pas trop mais
là c'est vrai que que la montagne c'est
sympa quoi et ça franchement c'est un
truc qui qui coule quoi en plus je
connais bien là-bas parce que j'avais ma
grand-mère qui avait un appartement
là-bas dans la zone si vous voulez
squatter si vous voulez mais
c'est vrai qu'en fait elle avait un
appartement aux Deux Alpes parce que tu
connais et bon c'est bon c'est c'est la
[__] c'est par là-bas et donc je
connais bien la zone c'est vraiment
hyper bien plus on était là-bas c'est
trop cool quoi
mais bon voilà après je fais pas souvent
sur la France c'est un peu nuaise
dernière semaine
d'août venez nombreux ça sera beau moi
j'y serai voilà tout ce que je peux vous
dire
est-ce que tu veux gagner si je gagne je
continue c'est génial si je gagne c'est
moi j'y connais mon frère tu sais c'est
l'immigration directe j'adore ah oui
super
bouder mais après rando rando tu vois
rando sympa
et si je gagne quand on gagne on est
toujours content bah oui non bah c'est
clair c'est clair
ça d'ailleurs
je sais pas on verra mais je quand même
pas mal de temps cet été j'ai pas trop
envie d'en faire non plus trop
il y a 2 ans
et là actuellement virtuellement votre à
ne pense pas quand je suis mental
si tu es à 2399 qui a un mec à 2500 qui
te propose nul dit oui oui ça c'est ça
je le ferai bon après il faut il faut
qu'il me propose lui déjà
donc il me respecte
[Musique]
mais bon
on verra toute façon
là je vais sûrement jouer la Ligue le
championnat des Canaries par équipe
c'est un truc que je vais trouver
donc il y a cette ronde
ça sera en juin
voilà après j'ai fait ma troisième norme
en 2016 donc bon
[Musique]
90 85 75 j'ai fait tous les vélos j'ai
tout fait mais bon une longue histoire
[Musique]
son équipe mais là il va jouer là-bas il
va falloir rando il aura du sport il va
être content quoi mais il va pas jouer
d'échec
[Musique]
avec
de baignoire minimum
on fait tu passes ta petite pub ouais
à l'image les chaises secrètes Lab allez
voir sur le site évidemment c'est le
chef evel Masters si vous me connaissez
pas de chez seven qu'est-ce que c'est
Chelsea c'est des cours interactifs non
pas interactif pas du tout ce sont des
cours d'échecs vous pouvez suivre avec
beaucoup d'explications en vidéo les top
joueurs qui vous présente leurs
ouvertures les finales et milieux de jeu
allez voir chelseables Dotcom vous y
trouverez votre bonheur si vous voulez
progresser aux échecs
mais quand même vous mettre toutes les
potes parce que on m'a demandé de le
faire donc juste un il faut que je fasse
une pause une pub on reste là mais on
revient dans une minute à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est dans tours désolé pour les
pubs c'est
étonné tu vois la fille dans la vidéo
qui a pas aidé le gars à ramasser ses
pièces alors que je pense qu'à l'inverse
le mec il aurait été gentleman il aurait
aidé à ranger les pièces ça montre bien
un petit peu la différence tu vois les
hommes et les femmes pas tout si tu veux
commencer le petit sujet
à tout là dessus
elle est assez chaude là dessus on peut
la Lancer
[Musique]
même je suis pas comme ça
mon livre sort bientôt vous inquiétez
pas vraiment livre plus vidéo attention
ça sera un truc de je vous fais un truc
de qualité là oh là là j'espère que
faudra aller acheter obligé live time
répertoire toute votre vie pourrait
jouer jusqu'à la fin de vos jours
ça sera beau avec ce truc ce sera très
travaillé et c'est pour tout niveau quoi
tout niveau tout est expliqué tout
niveau façon il tchèque en fait le
problème c'est qu'on me demande quel
niveau mais tu vois moi ma base tu vois
je me dis ce qu'on m'a dit c'est 1600
1800 mais le problème c'est que 1600800
parce que c'est là où tu as le plus de
joueurs et bien ils vont vérifier la la
database des parties par correspondance
ils ont stocké aussi donc tu es obligé
de faire en fait un truc quand même
assez poussé de toute façon donc et pour
tous les niveaux j'explique tout
honnêtement je crois qu'il y aura pas de
ça sera ça sera vraiment tout niveau
alors après faut connaître un minimum
les autres parce que tu commences par
e4c5 à 3 tu vois donc tu expliques
pourquoi c'est pas bon faut prendre le
centre tout ça donc
à partir de 1400 1500 je pense que ça
sera bon
je pense que c'est intéressant de voir
parce que par exemple
ce que je propose sur la Rousseau limo
c'est complètement pas complètement
nouveau mais tu vois ça a été au niveau
de la ligne le concept est est très très
rare
d'ailleurs avec le match avec le match
oublie de changer la caméra bah le match
Carlsen Kawana
avec ces gros débat théoriques sur la
sur la
et je pense que je il y a une ligne que
je propose la ligne principale que je
trouve que je préfère maintenant par
rapport à celle qui a été joué pendant
le match
ok je me moque pas des gens mais le
problème c'est que ça prend du temps
enfin ça prend du temps parce que je
suis pas je suis principalement
c'est
comme ça on se refait pas
ouais
digeste ah oui ça c'est pas un truc que
tu vas bosser en deux heures Guillaume
Le Petit Prince il faut que tu aies faut
que tu aies du temps devant toi
alors on regarde peut-être cette partie
où j'ai joué beaucoup de parties dans
cette ligne avec les avec les Blancs et
avec les noirs et j'ai même analysé ce
truc là pour Manu c'était notre prépa
pour China et en 2013
et voilà à 5 était un ordre de coup qui
nous qui nous embêtait
et maintenant sur ouh là il a fait il a
vraiment fait Kate prend ses trois
bon il faut F5 est normalement le coup
ici
qui est quand même le coup considéré
comme le meilleur avec l'idée de sur par
exemple si tu fais cavalier H4
je pensais trois quatre
[Musique]
décision sur le sur le pion c'est ma
partie contre le Masi je pense en
Bundesliga bon ok donc il change de
il prend en C3
je me suis dit je vais suivre son
exemple et je vais me dégonfler pareil
et du coup bah ça doit être une partie
de dégonfler
et une nul rapide
quand même
oui non mais je pensais que tu avais tu
avais juste
une mauvaise partie quoi
[Musique]
je me plains beaucoup plus quand je
perds
c'est qu'il y a une huile en 20 coups et
que il s'est pas passé grand chose voilà
ça va
très bien
mais la manière laquelle tu l'avais
annoncé je pensais que tu avais perdu
et c'est super contre un contre un
joueur du style Barbot pour ça
n'arrivera peut-être pas mais j'ai pas
perdu je te rappelle j'ai fait nul oui
mais c'est une défaite pas la dernière
fois que j'ai perdu contre le joueur
c'est une défaite de faire du combat
une grosse défaite c'est une énorme
défaite
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise
d'ailleurs un petit match ensemble aussi
sur twitch et
avec avec
margother alors ce qui est bien pierre
c'est qu'on part sur son temps
je lui ai dit tomber une fois je
t'assure il est ah bon je suis tombé ça
fait pire ça fait deux minutes qu'on
part sur ton temps quand même il est il
est très bon pire il faut que tu lui
parles pendant les les parties tu es sûr
de gagner mais je suis pas sûr qu'on va
pas
pour les gens tu dis c'est plus sympa
pour les gens tu l'embrouilles il va
dire oui oui et tu vas voir mais tu vas
pas aller sur ton temps mais si je
commence à perdre niveau troll il est
assez fort aussi donc
[Musique]
ça peut mal tourner je sais pas j'ai pas
autant de contrôle que toi quand même à
la position
donc on peut voir
je t'assure que c'est sûr qu'il parle
beaucoup
il y a quand même pour l'instant il y a
un partout dans tous les matchs c'est
simple Magnus a perdu grosse surprise a
perdu avec les paroles en première et là
il est c'est il est revenu avec les
noirs de manière très convaincante mais
artemief qui a ce péché mignon de se
mettre mal au temps et encore une fois
on voit il souffre un petit peu j'aime
pas trop comment il a traité cette
position
les blancs sont un peu
chacun de gars il a vraiment des
dossiers sur nous j'ai perdu contre
travail
il est plus jeune que Pierre et plus
dangereux quoi
là il a un style il a un style un peu
particulier quand même ouais j'aime pas
tu vois il est pas il est pas
contrôlable à notre ami
c'est la rentrée dangereux
pierre c'est coup on les voit arriver
quand même
qu'est-ce que tu en penses là les blancs
sont un peu mieux non
il va faire fou B2 le champion du monde
encore pendant une semaine
[Musique]
je vais faire peut-être mettre une dame
en B5 tu sais ça peut être très souvent
très embêtant quand tu as joué à 5 un
peu tout le monde et bien des trois dame
B5 et s'attaque Bessèges s'attaque des 5
et c'est dangereux il faut il faut
essayer de contrôler un petit peu les
gaz les cases
du coup c'est impossible il y a un
vis-à-vis
il y a une meilleure structure en fait
on sent qu'il y a un défaut structure
chez noir avec à 5 ça donne des cases
blanches on le sent
pas ouvert la colonne peut-être au
prochain coup intéressant et salut très
amical à notre ami d'Agen il est naze
qui méritait de se qualifier
et bon malheureusement il n'a qu'à
quasiment pas mais c'est vrai que chaque
fois c'est c'est les derbies Agen on les
a joué en Coupe de France on les a joué
enfin à chaque fois c'est le gros derby
pour pour une montée ou un truc et c'est
vrai que
la revanche au rugby parce que Agen
reste s'en sortir
avec nous on a on a une moyenne d'âge
qui est un petit peu affaibli là du coup
derrière
alors j'ai 4
est-ce qu'on fait j'ai 4 ou pas j'ai 4
ans OK
et là tu veux faire ton Dame des trois
peut-être parce qu'en fait j'ai
l'impression que tu menaces pas faut
prendre 5 il faut prendre les quatre
alors on peut regarder juste pour
expliquer un petit peu
donc il y a aussi le bout de case noire
qui pour l'instant la catégorie est
fermée mais on sait pas et c'est vrai
que pour un câble F3
[Musique]
c'est ce que je parce que c'est
maintenant ou jamais parce que
finalement il y a une petite faiblesse
sur casse blanche comme tu le disais
mais quand elle a position si on regarde
les pièces c'est quand même très très
symétrique cette histoire donc il faut
quand même se dépêcher clairement
il y a un partout toujours c'est vrai
que ça serait sympa de peut-être pour
demain on va améliorer on va s'améliorer
mais de mettre un petit score
je pense que ça ferait pas de mal au
stream quand même pour les gens qui nous
rejoignent
je pense que c'est sympa de mettre un
petit un partout je vais te montrer un
truc à la main jamais le voir là tu vas
rajouter du texte
[Musique]
ou la propulse 89 c'est compliqué les
les histoires des candidats on verra ça
c'est pas tout de suite il y a le
Championnat du Monde qui arrive on le
rappelle à suivre évidemment sur
cheescom FR
le championnat du monde entre dingly
rain et
Yann n'est pas bien chi qui sera
commenté évidemment tous les jours à
partir du Kazakhstan les parties
commencent à 11h ce sera sur cette même
chaîne à partir du 9 avril
donc voilà ça sera
ça sera magnifique
est-ce qu'on peut jouer les parties si
on est malade alors je pense que pendant
le covid la la période covid était
propice à ce genre de choses mais je
crois plus maintenant maintenant si on
est malade on est malade et voilà bah
quelques kilomètres comme dans tous les
sports quelqu'un qui est blessé au
tennis bah il fait fort faire c'est
comme ça c'est
c'est triste mais c'est comme ça
on peut poser toutes les questions ici
c'est pas sûr que c'est tituler les
réponses c'est tout c'est la question
c'est ça la réponse
alors on a le score qui va bientôt
s'afficher
partout est-ce que Magnus se décide d'y
réfléchir il réfléchit Magnus il le sent
il est très très fort c'est un des
nombreux points forts de manuscrite bien
le moment critique dans une partie et il
passe du temps il est pas comme parce
qu'il a une qualité de plus par rapport
à notamment celle-là il a plus de
qualité évidemment que tu aimes bien
mais sur celle-là oui vraiment il
utilise son temps au moment opportun je
dirais
qui va gagner je sais pas mais non moi
je préfère digne mais je crois que
je crois que
je crois que nepo est favori
malheureusement
on verra après ça reste très très serré
hein donc
[Musique]
on va voir et
ouais après celui qui à mon avis ce qui
est la première partie et dans favori
parce que
les pots quand il commence à gagner il
s'arrête plus et quand il commence à
perdre il s'arrête plus en plus donc il
marche beaucoup à la confiance donc je
crois que ce qui est la première partie
aura un gros gros avantage est-ce que je
vais commenter non non
sur la chaîne
ok
donc
trois je pense regarde l'idée
[Musique]
trois à cause de la vie il a pas aimé le
coucher 4 c'est vrai que le gars c'est
quand même
sur le roi aussi notamment et tout va
vite maintenant et ben on va sûrement
avoir deux avec les dames B5
et en plus c'est une idée très connue
donc Magnus il va le je pense qu'il va
jouer même assez rapidement d'un meude
ici c'est une saliver tour c'est un coup
tellement naturel
aussi rapidement
donc il va jouer demain contre le
gagnant de you
contre je vais voir je vais vous dire en
fait ça a commencé une heure une heure
plus tôt donc
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a deux parties
plus de résultats et cramique qui a
gagné deux et demi 1 et demi super donc
demain crânique mvl bon j'espère qu'on
va le suivre on va le suivre
à 16h par contre là je vois je commence
un petit peu peut-être mais je crois
qu'on va le suivre franchement
le reste
il est pas là
quoi
donc qualifié pour
pour demain
ça va être un beau match j'ai pas
exactement l'horaire de demain je vais
regarder voir si on peut les avoir les
horaires
on verra ça priori on sera là pour tous
les réseaux suivez-nous sur les réseaux
sociaux n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
sur nos chaînes twitch YouTube
les réseaux sociaux de chaise comme fr
comme ça vous vous avez tout des notifs
et sur le média que vous préférez
évidemment mais vous avez toutes les
notifs et ça vous permet de ne rien
rater parce que c'est toujours annoncé
donc c'est quand même
très sympa de faire ça et ça vous permet
de rien rater merci à j'avais raté le
message de un mot F qui nous dit j'adore
vous expliquer et bien ça fait plaisir à
quatre jouets par Magnus ça veut dire
que en fait il a eu peur que sur dame 2
il y a 4 vous voyez Magnus personne qui
est le roi de la précision mais ça veut
dire qu'il veut faire des modes au
prochain coup pour faire dame B5
et ça c'était pas possible
ça marche jamais dans le B5
et là il fait dame B6 pour empêcher dame
ok tout tout tourne autour de ce de ce
mb5 vous pouvez voir surtout le sur tous
les sur tous les sites les résultats
alors deux questions benitos question
perso je viens je reviens souvent sur le
sud de la côte atlantique tout à fait
est-ce que qui est pour toi celui qui
est le plus digne d'être successeur de
Carlson je sais pas lire ça
[Musique]
parce que si tu veux tout le travail
qu'il faut que je fasse pour peut-être
l'être ça va pas forcément
demain je gagne au loto ben j'ai plus de
problème tu vois peut-être que je me dis
bah tiens j'ai bossé un peu
[Musique]
là bon bah il faut travailler soi-même
je travaille mes échecs donc t'as pas
forcément envie après ta grosse journée
de cours plus stream plus tout ça de de
enfin tu vois c'est un peu la motivation
qui
[Musique]
des fois je des fois je je
j'aimerais bien travailler des fois un
truc qui n'est pas les déchets parce
qu'en fait
moi j'adore les chèques ma passion mais
mais
j'ai plus envie de travailler parce que
parce que
quelqu'un qui qui fait autre chose dans
sa vie et ben quoi qu'il voit des échecs
c'est un peu aussi un moyen de sortir un
peu de ces journées voilà ton quotidien
quoi donc moi voilà je je sais que ça va
rien apporter d'être
donc après oui j'aimerais bien c'est
demain tu me donnes le titre je vais le
prendre
mais voilà j'ai pas j'ai pas tous
l'effort faut faire pour l'être pour
peut-être l'être et encore je suis pas
sûr d'avoir
le talent et tout ça enfin c'est
beaucoup de choses
non plus donc
en fait compliqué à partir grand maître
normalement après déjà
25 si j'ai pas 25 30 25 30 ça commence à
être un petit peu dur
quand même assez il y a que Magnus qui
peut se permettre ce genre de truc il
faut prendre le 4 ok ça c'est une grosse
décision de me foutu fiancé tout alors
c'est un truc concret où on prend le 7
c'est ça l'idée
sur sur frurange je fais je fais tours
C8 et il a fait tout repenser
intermédiaire
et surtout
la colonne
mais ça fait un peu peur
le terme C3
[Musique]
je comprends pas faut prendre
un petit peu
l'amour
très très bizarre et attention 3,25 pour
Magnus et 5 minutes une fois n'est pas
coutume artemief devant autant
[Musique]
celle-là il faut il faut pas la dernière
fois
pour l'instant là on est on est à deux
parties les deux victoires se sont joués
donc ça veut rien dire mais bon gagner
sur commande avec les noirs
effectivement ça serait pas une bonne
nouvelle et là je pense qu'il est
simplement la jauge à l'air de confirmer
que les noirs sont mieux le temps aussi
compliqué est-ce qu'il va redevenir
champion du monde the world the creal
hell et ben c'est ce qu'il y a déjà le
désir alors on parlait de voilà est-ce
qu'il a envie de rejeter match je l'ai
candidats il faut déjà qu'il y a un
changement de formule faut qu'ils se
dépêche aussi à 32 ans donc peut-être il
peut il a très certainement les
capacités est-ce qu'il va le faire je
crois que lui-même ne le sait pas et je
pense que ça dépend de un peu de du
format c'est des changements du futur
champion et ce genre de choses
F3
F3 qui est une gaffe d'après la jauge
personne
G4 alors c'est un intermédiaire ou pas
pour C8 fousser 5 il faut calculer
je te laisse faire j'ai beaucoup de
choses en prise
j'ai la flemme de calculer donc je bouge
mon fou
je suis venu hyper paresseux avant je
fais maintenant je calcule plus rien
j'ai la flemme
ça c'est à moi ce porte quand même mais
ça m'arrive tout le temps
89 c'était quoi F15
ça existe plus hein
[Rires]
c'est comme si j'étais 94 pour toi en
quoi
d'accord faut que tu gagnes non mais
j'ai compris je comprends que le concept
je comprends que tu mets deux fois plus
de points en jeu
donc ok ouais tu es vraiment tu es à une
victoire une belle victoire de ouais
ouais bon après
tu as une victoire contre un joueur un
peu mieux classé de du titre ben là j'ai
une partie d'Inter club enfin un grand
maître à 2395 là sur mon île aux
Canaries
si je le batte 99
mais je pense que j'aurais pas la partie
je serai pas là
[Musique]
pour jouer à trois coups et je serai
reparti après
c'est le grand maître qui propose nu à
chaque fois en bout de 5 coups et à
chaque fois je refuse à chaque fois je
perds
alors
au niveau des
tests au niveau des commentaires ça a
été racheté
on est tous ensemble sur cheesecom mais
puis voilà
donc
si il décide de reprendre aussi que
champion du monde oui question et mes
relations avec Magnus sont Top Office
bon bah il joue pas toi de partir en
classe en particulier c'est ça un peu le
souci est comme une deure de travailler
pendant les tournois de partie classique
comme il en joue pas mais ça devient
compliqué le prochain étant dans
watchesse mais j'ai mon j'ai le Top 16
juste un pile poil en même temps donc
c'est pas qu'on joue beaucoup tous les
deux mais il se trouve que les trois
sont en même temps donc là
là non en ce moment c'est un petit peu
stand-by mais effectivement ça peut ça
peut reprendre si ce si ce
on l'a dit il le joue et on va avoir la
réponse on va voir c'est simple
on prend F5 je suppose c'est la ligne et
B6 quelque chose comme ça vous prend le
5 d'abord et B6 c'est vrai que c'est
complexe parce qu'il y a des Damas 3 tu
vois par exemple
attention attention très très compliqué
non non
on va montrer cette ligne peut-être
Stéphane damso3
je peux manger là essayer de triquer
[Musique]
j'ai pas j'ai pas un truc sur l'option 3
c'est pas complètement inenvisageable
mais effectivement il y a une qualité de
plus pour les blancs ça a l'air mieux
pour les blancs donc va prendre
maintenant ça a pas le coup
est-ce que j'ai un meilleur coup que ça
que je peux pas manger au 5 j'ai pas
assez malheureusement faire
aussi qui est possible
il y a tellement de d'options F5 il faut
prendre 5 puis on prend le 5 je récupère
la pièce
comme ça montrer ouais c'est ça non
et on a une fier de toi avantageuse
d'ailleurs
non non c'est la partie tu m'as fait
peur
[Musique]
un peu en zone mat pour éviter que le
roi s'active trop
mais les pions
la tournoi est très active donc il faut
éviter que le la tour et le roi sont
actif parce que sinon ça demande au
vinaigre
de de maths donc ça serait vraiment
horrible comme coup les champions
maintenant j'ai plus j'ai plus le coup
aussi donc par exemple comme tour C6 et
ben j'aurais peut-être tourner un qui
vient en fait avoir un peu contre jeu
sur les pions donc en fait c'est bon
[Musique]
je prends tout
revient sur la 7e
ou pas mais ok et qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a plein de coups une huile chacun
donc on va revenir évidemment en direct
non c'est la partie incroyable on est
bon on a rien dire
dans cette finale c'est une évidence une
tête de nul ces trucs là
on va se créer un pion passé mais moi
j'ai quand même aussi un peu passé F et
je peux activer
ça ne m'étonnerait pas parce que
l'artémir attention technique très très
fine de arte mais vraiment c'est pour
gros point fort grosse technique
d'artémiables en finale il est très
dangereux un déverge du monde en finale
on va rester là pour défendre il y a
toujours la poussée qui va qui va se
faire mais ça prend du temps tout ça
voilà 5 ok il veut garder l'option
F4 3G4 belle technique très
j'ai envie de dire c'est un peu
même s'il était
il était pas né mais c'est un peu
l'école soviétique qui est resté sur
Artémis on commence à tu vois ce truc il
a dû avoir un entraîneur soviétique au
départ tu vois de l'ancienne génération
parce qu'il a appris les finales
directes ça c'est sûr ça se voit c'est
marrant ça se voit sur les joueurs ou tu
vois tu sens qu'il a pas qui a trahi les
finales d'entrée à 8 ans il faisait des
finales 8 heures par jour
parce que là il a une technique qui est
vraiment absolument toujours impeccable
très très impressionnant
alors il va falloir
attention j'ai l'impression de tomber 7
est quand même une menace
donc
mon roi et des pions et ça peut ça peut
ah mais il a raté toi
OK
moi je prendrai cela
je pense
4h des options comme ça
ta technique ta technique soviétique
Stéphane
[Musique]
il fait le tour il fait le tour 12 fois
il s'est fait couper manuscarsen il aime
pas ça se faire couper je vous le dis
j'ai 4 j'ai 4 va arriver à mon avis
de progresser ouais j'ai quatre jouets
j'ai quatre F3 roi G5 et après tu
essaies de créer H5 H4 j'ai trouvé en
fait c'est ça le plan
H4
du coup
ça a l'air franchement
[Musique]
si tu prends là
va être très très gros coup dur pour
Magnus c'est hyper ce premier match
attention il sera sur le fil du rasoir
jusqu'à la fin du tournoi il n'aura plus
le droit à l'erreur énorme énorme match
d'artemief qui avec les Noirs montre
toute sa classe et toute sa technique
vraiment deux fois deux fois même avec
les Noirs c'est pas donné à tout le
monde
alors qu'est-ce qui nous reste
comme partie on a un Caravana
hop je vais vous montrer celle-là
alors
c'est une forteresse normalement
ce genre de truc ça perd jamais parce
que vous voyez ce cavalier stable un F5
c'est très important vous voyez si le
cavalier a quelque chose pour le
protéger c'est très important c'est
final qui soit stable et là il est tout
dépendu en fait tout est défendu et il y
a pas de faiblesse
[Musique]
c'est fini
donc surprise il prend la tête de un
pour lui partout entre ouais c'est chaud
et Levana rognan et caroanna alekwang si
ça fait nul ça a déjà fait nul
dans le prochain parti et dans l'objet
de gagner rappelons que celle-ci hyper
il est pas encore éliminé parce que
comme tu viens de le montrer ah non non
je regardais mais j'ai pas les trucs
c'est pas mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que il est pas éliminé et il
mais par contre il aura plus du tout le
droit à l'erreur c'est un double
élimination donc voilà salut à toi
Walter model je crois qu'on va faire un
petit break mon cher on fait un petit
break donc
on revient en cinq minutes et pour la
dernière ronde de cette journée avec 45
qui doit absolument gagner que les Noirs
n'a qu'à moi qui est aussi absolument
gagner et karwana le Kang et aaronianso
qui sont à égalité avec un point et demi
chacun et voilà de finaliste du premier
tournoi qui sont dos au mur pour
arracher des blistes de départage
attention c'est même pas la victoire
il faut qu'il gagne les deux avec les
Noirs le feront-ils réponse dans 5
minutes à tout de suite
on n'est pas encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est de retour avec Laurent pour
cette
cette quatrième partie qui va démarrer
donc on vous rappelle les scores Artémis
qui vient de battre deux fois Carlson
avec les Noirs mène 2-1 et il reste une
seule partie donc pour pousser qu'un
seul département
encore une fois c'est marrant de voir
quatre parties quatre gamins
et tu me le rappelais à la pause donc le
effectivement tu as tout à fait raison
le système de départage qui serait pas à
des Blitz mais un système à enchères
avec un Armageddon on a 15 minutes les
Noirs ont les draw hots comme on dit
celle-ci fond nul ils gagnent et les
joueurs mettent un temps sous enveloppe
et celui qui a donné le temps le plus
bas avec les Noirs prends les noirs et
la dernière fois ce qui s'est passé
entre minuscar sanic à un accueil
en fait ils ont décidé en gros ils se
sont dit tous les deux le cut le bon cut
il est à 9 minutes donc icaru Nakamura
vous la jouer au plus malin a mis 8,59
mai
8 58 évidemment sans voir l'enchère de
du Caron
c'est assez extraordinaire bon
inutile de vous dire qu'après un coup
pareil il a fait nul
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez énorme ce qu'il avait fait
donc voilà chacun sa juste alors
peut-être contre artemief qui est assez
lent ça peut ça peut augmenter un petit
peu c'est à dire que Magnus ce serait
pas mécontent de jouer à 15,9 donc ça
dépend du style de son adversaire donc
c'est un peu voilà ça donne un peu de
piment
ces enchères et je trouve que c'est un
format très sympa
vous avez
vous avez les
caméras qui sont là je vais d'ailleurs
changer aussi les scores parce que
donc cette tâche qui est d'habitude et
pas si difficile mais en tout cas dans
ce match faire mieux avec les Blancs
c'est pas arrivé pour l'instant ils ont
perdu du noir ont tout gagné pour
l'instant est-ce que ça va durer on va
voir Magnus qui est évidemment capable
de revenir sur cette partie on va
l'assurer avec intérêt car on a la
caméra aussi dans les cornes ça serait
une grosse surprise de les voir dans les
600 tous les deux dans le braquet des
perdants ça veut dire que déjà ils vont
rejouer ensemble avant de rejouer que
d'autres ceux qui sont dans le braquet
des vainqueurs donc ça fera un des deux
éliminer ça c'est sûr
ça a commencé
ça commence donc Artémis blanc contre
Carlson
étant obligatoirement
il joue solide il joue dans son style
alors c'est toujours c'est toujours
tentant avec les Blancs d'essayer de
jouer les ventes forcées pour essayer de
faire nul mais effectivement
là il fait pas du tout ça et il joue son
truc habituel à des quatre changements
par rapport à d'habitude ou pas
et des six ok c'est ce que j'ai loué
dans ma première dans ma c'était la
position que j'ai eu dans ma partie de
samedi tu m'as parlé de cette partie de
ce samedi
qui était à
2570 il y a 2 ans qui a 2430 maintenant
il a eu un confinement je vais être
enfermer c'est ce qui m'a raconté après
je voulais des tours à fermer en Serbie
ou des jeunes Indiens venaient faire des
normes de grand maître
enfin venez essayer de faire des normes
de grand-mère et ça c'est assez mal
passé pour
pour
cette laque oui un peu perdu à confiance
et tout c'est dur quand tu commences à
perdre et c'est toi qui avait 7 c'est
pas parti tu sais il a joué à 4 ici ah
ben voilà c'est pas parti
j'apprends des meilleurs
on a joué une fille dehors c'est un peu
une preuve joke
en Top 16 où tu étais très très bien
préparé c'est top 12 à l'époque en fait
c'était bluffé mais je n'étais pas
en fait non mais en fait en fait
la ligne qu'on a joué c'est la seule que
j'ai pas rêvé et je me souvenais plus
qu'il fallait faire et c'était une
langue hyper compliqué et quand je peux
plus c'est le cavalier H5 avec
mais je savais que c'était cool mais je
te l'ai joué avec tellement plein je me
suis levé clairement c'est le coup de
poker quoi pour te dire ok je suis
préparé à fond dessus et finalement tu
es revenu froid je suis bien content
mais
tu me jouais le coup donc j'étais bluffé
mais je me souvenais plus mais je vais
travailler j'ai des bases mais sauf que
j'avais
oublié tu sais que jusqu'à Dame des
trois on a parlé
c'est ça
et donc c'était ma partie au lieu de
jouer Dame des trois mon adversaire je
veux 4 il regarde tout donc il a dû
réfléchir et tout voilà typiquement
quand on demande combien de temps
minuscule
passe de temps à travailler les échecs
par jour mais voilà typiquement je suis
sûr qu'il a pas les aiglesi il a vu ma
partie en Bundes parce qu'il regarde des
parties en mode de salamuse voilà il
aime bien et il a vu ce truc il se dit
c'est pas bête c'est 6 dames c'est cette
qui a été improvisé de ma part devant
l'échiquier et donc et en fait mon
adversaire va jouer Dame des trois
jeunes 15 j'ai joué 5 et j'ai une
position à peu près normale et du coup
artemief connaissait il se trouve qu'il
y a un peu de théorie mais très peu en
fait c'est une position pas du tout
connu elle est deux joueurs jouent quand
même assez rapidement et on a vu après
dame détruire je tourne vite Magnus
alors ça j'avais pas la raie fait
tourner un joué par
artemief donc on n'a pas envie alors je
vais montrer l'idée ici pour les blancs
c'est que sur le 5 on fait puis on prend
puis on prend et on joue quelle idée et
l'idée alors on va jouer cahier des deux
et on veut justement t'as montré la case
des 6 qui est très importante on va
essayer de faire justement euh ces
quatre et cahier des 6 ensuite peut-être
B3 fois 3 si on s'organise et c'est pour
ça qu'on a on a envie d'atteindre 4 pour
faire E5 avec les Noirs alors il y a un
moment où on va quand même on a beaucoup
préparé au sein qu'on a quand même être
obligé de le jouer effectivement pour en
revenir à notre fil d'or ouais j'avais
joué ça contre Thomas ou je m'étais
trompé comme un crétin une partie de
matin au bout de stickers je m'étais
trompé et j'avais joué la mauvaise
variante et je joue la bonne vente
contre toi
[Musique]
et on avait analysé pendant
c'est intéressant on a analysé longtemps
et avec Paulo Mario on avait
l'analyse va durer plus longtemps que la
partie
régulièrement au bout de sliga mais pas
parce que je perds tu vois
pas très longtemps et donc faut bien
s'occuper jusqu'à l'avion quoi et puis
c'est toujours sympa discuter échec
on passe tellement de temps devant
l'ordi maintenant moi j'adore c'est pas
ce mortels parce que tu vois tu
t'échanges sans ordi tu connais pas lui
évaluation et donc du coup
d'un avis humain en face de toi qui est
qui est quand même
tellement sympathique par rapport à ces
lignes
d'ailleurs il a fait 100 % dans la
saison
4 sur 4
[Musique]
il y a pas eu trop de suspense à chaque
fois
pareil
j'aimais pas ça tu sais pourquoi
j'aimais pas ça par la partie parce
qu'il y avait au 5 j'ai eu peur de 5 sur
E4 j'ai hésité à jouer tout revu de
d'abord mais je me suis il y a eu 5
maintenant et comment je fais
tomber vite d'abord parce qu'on regarde
E5 puis on prend puis on prend on va
montrer la la ligne elle est très simple
cavalier prend cavalier prend dame prend
F4 et on voit le problème d'avoir joué
pour V8
je pense que je sais pas alors bon
Magnus évidemment
ça c'est typique dans la vidéo et ça
empêche de la vie ouais et c'est ce que
je fais aussi souvent on se positionner
j'ai joué tomber vite et ben ça comme ça
qu'il a pas fait alors vas-y je vais te
montrer la pour revenir deux de quoi en
arrière parce qu'elle est très très
similaire non non parce qu'en fait il a
joué au catch j'ai joué 5 ah ok
très très similaire
puis on prend ABA B et en fait les noirs
sont déjà ok des 5 il a joué 2005 et oui
ça c'est la pollution
que j'ai
en plus avec le forger 7 qui est
peut-être mieux ou pas
souvent tu peux même avoir cette
pollution avec le fond pour et en fait
au final c'est des positions un peu de
nageoire
[Musique]
c'est c'est assez intéressant
et après
avoir perdu contre moi et descendu à
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il va jouer le 5 c'est la
partie fd7
ok d'accord ok très intéressant
es fr peut-être pas je sais pas mais en
tout cas il est dans les Alpes
voilà on dira allez-y à la recherche de
manus scarlsen dans les Alpes si vous
voulez un autographe vous pouvez aller
le matin il fait des randonnées c'est
100% j'ai passé une semaine avec lui
dans les Alpes tous les matins il
regardait la carte et il voulait pas
travailler il voulait faire des
randonnées puis là il va peut-être avoir
du temps libre pour faire des randonnées
grâce à des miettes
on va voir
bien skate focus son tournoi et en fait
il pourrait perdre ton premier temps
après le niveau est mon spa et après il
y a un match on peut se refaire on peut
se refaire
demain ça peut être terminé ça veut dire
que maintenant il a vraiment grosse
pression est-ce que Artémis fait affiché
à cavalier prend le 5 il est il est
inquiet par rapport à cette à cette
variante
alors qu'est-ce qu'on veut du coup
[Musique]
c'est pas si évident
et si tu bouges le cavalier 4 par
exemple je sais pas un truc là tête sur
ça j'ai du BK
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça j'aime pas du tout
position de Magnus qui est dans une
situation de de victoire obligatoire
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal Lucas va
dépendre
du match aussi
un site à jouer à jouer à ses safe
donc on va voir on va voir ce que va
être la réponse de Magnus est-ce que
cavalier prend puis on prend que G4 et
une option moi j'aime bien ça
parce que sur F4 j'aime bien mais la
jauge j'aime pas en général il faut plus
se fier que moi F4 B5
[Musique]
mais c'est pas si grave parce que le fou
de le foot G7 est tellement en muré par
les pions par la structure des Noirs
vous avez des règles qui font que oui il
est fort mais des fois on peut avoir
on peut donner ces pièces là en fait si
pas comme tout à l'heure un quartier il
a fait pour prendre un cadre qu'on a pas
trop compris mais dans l'idée des fois
on peut faire des coups un peu
surprenant comme ça si on considère que
nos pièces les pièces qui vont rester
sont plus fortes que d'autres donc la F4
c'est une idée
ce que je peux donner le pion je pense à
toi ma carte est-ce qu'on dit un
scandale le département là il y a des il
y a des curieux bon des derniers
Haute-Savoie Bruno
à la destination de de Magnus
ou pas
la dame de Haute-Savoie
donc
[Musique]
je faisais fu F5 je sais pas
F4 très logique et la jauge aime bien
les blancs mais c'est vrai que Magnus
et sur foue F5 ici j'ai l'impression
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
bon je vais de
j'ai l'impression qu'on va tout
simplement reculer en fait si on se fait
attaquer on recule la dame et ton patron
et après on va les on va on va repousser
tranquillement les pièces
niveau temps là là ça va il est encore 9
minutes à la pendule il est pas en
retard vraiment
est-ce qu'on considère que l'ouverture
est complètement ratée pour maintenir
parce qu'il a quand même une position tu
vois
à double tranchant clairement bon elle
est pas très bonne mais on sent qu'il y
a des il y a du potentiel quand même
alors c'est ouvert quand même
on est d'accord mais
bon
on voit ouais trop jeune Arnaud 1933
Paris ouais trop jeune soufflé il y a
pas la rêve désolé
[Rires]
depuis qu'on a joué F4 mais il faut dire
que c'est pas une super pièce
donc donc peut-être que c'est d'ouvrir à
gazon
mais là clairement le planning noir ça
va être
autour des vitesses pour
magnuste hein
l'ordinateur il est il aime bien les
blancs parce qu'il y a l'Espace il y en
a partout il y a plein de choses mais en
fait
pratique il y a encore pas mal de choses
on voit que le fruit pas développé ce
qui fait que la Tour est un petit peu en
prise quand même hein prétendait de
faire attention il y a toujours du B5
sur gaz noir
[Musique]
c'est pas encore clair franchement
très bien passé 4 minutes ça arrangerait
évidemment Magnus il essaie de
compliquer à fond à ce qui c'est il
connaît évidemment cette tendance
d'artemief de passer beaucoup de temps
sur les sur les positions
[Musique]
ça serait vraiment une horreur complète
on ne peut pas faire ça
qu'on a envie de jouer mais bon
je préfère
c'est rendu à l'évidence en grande
difficulté là je crois j'ai 4
pour faire je crois que je prends ma
petite barrière et c'est le truc
quoi j'ai la chance avec les Noirs parce
que les perdants vont s'ouvrir je sais
pas s'il va prendre
F6 je le fais F5
puis on prend F5 et puis on prend le jeu
quand on fout de caisse blanche qui me
paraît avoir très peu de cases
[Musique]
tu vois le dynamisme par rapport au
matériel c'est important qu'en fait
beaucoup de gens ont reculé parce que le
foot en prison
pas souvent c'est bien de donner un pion
pour activer les pièces plutôt que de
rester comme ça et pas bouger
il a dû voir quelque chose quand même
parce que
possible attention alors F6 force les
blancs à prendre une décision et non F5
maintenant la période du temps
toujours toujours là
et oui parce qu'il y a pas de couilles
F6 puis on prend puis on prend
certainement moi je vois jouer artemie
là tu comprends
j'ai la case F7 pour Madame si tu viens
en B5
donc j'ai un petit peu amélioré la
situation bon c'est très risqué mais ça
reste ça reste très jouable la super
c'est à son comble est-ce que manuscrit
va réussir à revenir tu aimes bien les
blancs quand même
de la cloche game tu sais la partie
c'est le roi c'est le roi dans les
parties décisives il est toujours
toujours la main ferme donc on va voir
il va tout faire pour pour
renverser la situation pour prenez le
crise ok alors F5 maintenant alors on
n'a pas regardé
mais c'est pas son idée c'est ça ça
je pense
[Musique]
quand même des pions
et la dame est peut-être ta cavalière
cavalier F5
et kf5 protège une pièce et on attaque
une autre bon ça devient ça devient très
chaud
[Musique]
c'est la partie jusque-là
mais je récupère
bien sûr que Magnus il prend ses trois
au sérieux c'est le seul qui joue déjà
sur Internet et en plus il voyage et
tout ça il fait il y a Peter et Nelson
qui est sur place bien sûr qu'il prend
ça au sérieux
il a gagné la dernière fois sans perdre
un seul match sans utiliser finalement
son droit à l'erreur il a gagné tous ces
matchs et il a battu deux fois et
caronakamura qui est revenu du bracket
des et des loosers entre guillemets des
perdants mais qui a qui a repris une
défaite contre
manuscrite alors il va aller où avec sa
dame
RTBF elle est compliquée cette position
manqueuse qui a réussi à compliquer la
position
quasi certain
[Musique]
donc il y a toujours un peu de jus donc
on mange de la tour bien sûr on va
garder les pièces
c'est la partie
ouais il va prendre la tour 100 %,
est-ce que intermédiaire qui légale ou
pas cavalier F5 m'a pas l'air légal à
cause de dames 1 attaque le fou aussi
les gars
ça veut dire parce que ça perd pas trop
de matériel déjà qu'on a investi pas mal
à moi à moins que la finale soit est-ce
qu'elle est si perdante que ça la finale
mais il faut gagner c'est ça
il y a un problème tactique
c'est la fin des haricots
malheureusement je prends de la dame je
vais pas me prendre la tête
c'est une grande force de pouvoir faire
une quand tu veux et pas forcément
tous les risques avec quelqu'un de
[Musique]
je sais pas
je crois
tellement de choses
non non après c'est joli j'ai un joli
coup à te proposer présage 3 je vais
faire tout à 7 le très inattendu tour à
7 qui fait très très mal à mon avis on y
pensait pas on y pense déjà
je crois que c'est les carottes sont
vraiment cuites
donc attention il y a quand même en fait
tu vas créer la menace de tour à 7
vraiment
manger
je crois que la mort dans la vie va être
obligé de jouer de me prendre B8 il a
joué il va le faire parce qu'il a pas le
choix mais
là tu mangerais plutôt G4
je te replace pas ton cavalier direct si
je vois rien qui fait pas ça
peut-être pas mal aussi
un petit
[Musique]
objet de prendre je reprends et je me
Mastour des yeux
c'est très dur
c'est un peu le coup du
père de famille tu peux le dire
pousser un peu arbre
[Musique]
et tourner ici c'est tu actives ta tour
et tu donnes
sont cuites
qui devrait je pense pas ce genre s'il
est parti en résultats qui sont tombés
j'ai encore aucun résultat dans notre
attention
et si je prends là pour ces 5 rois là
ok bon c'est quand même dommage à
changer
du courage
en fait
c'est vraiment nul direct
[Musique]
j'ai pas de cas où je
peux pas ils sont pas accompagnés de
pièces j'ai mes pièces qui sont bien
détendu mon fou contre la Casa
pour gagner ça avec moi
faut se méfier est-ce que Roger 7 va
être joué je pense que oui
donc on est obligé de les garder alors
cahier des cinq laisse-moi essayer
cavalier F7 tu vas où je te pose des
questions si je mange
bah vas-y je fais non je fais gaffe
cette
par Magnus cars 7 qui garde son pion il
a raison
ce qui va faire qu'est-ce que tu veux
qu'il fasse il faut qu'il garde
donc on peut pas faire est-ce que je
commençais à regarder comme ça on va
montrer aux gens que c'est cette foudre
et là je fais un coup droit H2
tu vois
KFC par exemple
même celle-là exactement
alors c'est pas évident surtout à
un niveau si on n'a pas étudier c'est
très dur si on l'a étudié ça devient
très facile c'est toujours pareil et
mais évidemment pour ces joueurs de ce
niveau c'est de rigolade
[Musique]
qui streamait il avait en pratique il
avait maté en prime
donc bon
B3 Supercoupe
petit coin intermédiaire on attaque le
fou on attaque le pion et ensuite on va
jouer C4
c'est vraiment c'est facile c'est trop
facile pour de faire nul
alors 30 secondes peut-être le dernier
ouais mais ça m'a l'air quand même
mais
[Musique]
tu aimes bien
qui est revenu on a au moins un
taille-break Stéphane Nakamura
qui se dirige vers une nul donc au
deuxième timbreak avec ces fameuses aux
enchères restez avec nous on va voir ça
va être sympa et on a les vannes à
rognan qui est en train de perdre
contre wesleaux ça serait une victoire
de Wesley mais c'est pas fini on ira
voir peut-être cette partie des c'est
terminé chez le toujours triple champion
du monde plus pour très longtemps encore
un petit mois devant lui
[Musique]
alors cavalier F4 joué par
non mais c'est juste
il a toujours un dernier piège
au minimum
je sais pas ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est je serai pas ici en train de
compter d'ailleurs
il veut que tu ailles manger le pion
pendant ce temps-là essayer de faire un
truc quoi pour avoir
qui prend les quatre H2
le
je crois que je vais gagner cette partie
là tu as le sang
il y a eu cavaler là il y a le droit
il y a 5 secondes quand même pour pour
ranger 3 qu'est-ce qui nous fait art là
incroyable il a perdu mais il est tombé
regarde la tête
incroyable incroyable un craquage de
croix
que c'est dommage et on aura droit à des
tailles vrais qu'est-ce que tu avais
enterré
[Musique]
souvent en fait on est amené à jouer en
fait des mauvais coups parce qu'on
retient ses coups tu vois et là dans la
partie première bon il était
inconvénient quoi il avait en tout cas
un avantage
était très très bien et il a voulu
simplifier
et donc là psychologiquement ça peut lui
donner tout pour la dans la partie
mais il met 11 minutes parce que à moins
de 11 minutes il est content tu vois 15
parce que il est là quand même hein
c'est compliqué bon il va faire ça mieux
que moi vous inquiétez pas pour lui il
va l'embrouiller il aura la couleur qui
voudra à la fin on voit est-ce que tu as
la partie de Levon a Ronan contre c'est
la dernière et il est en train de gagner
ouais c'est chaud avec tous ces pions
quelle formidable professionnelle ce
Wesley
d'emballer l'affaire il y a deux il y a
une nuit partout donc c'est la c'est la
partie la décisive et il a gagné avec
les noirs
qui va se qualifier avec cette partie et
l'autre partie c'était quoi c'était le
Kawana
le Kong
4 dans une finale de Tours donc on va
avoir on va avoir normalement
deux départages
ce qui va se qualifier
personne qui va de partager contre
artania on va avoir
Nakamura qui qui a réussi à venir à
venir
à hauteur à hauteur
[Musique]
Nakamura
donc trois départages on va avoir donc
les départages on vous rappelle c'est
c'est des départages par
enchères enchères ça veut dire que on va
chacun proposer
une cadence
et celui qui donne le la cadence la plus
le moins de temps possible
c'est exactement c'est si il y a comme
effet Magnus 8,58 quand tu cinquante
neuf c'est la plus basse enchère qu'il
en porte peu importe ça soit d'une
seconde ou de 10 minutes donc en général
les joueurs se sont accordés là j'ai
l'impression que le consensus c'est aux
alentours de 9 minutes
à peu près équilibre alors après ça
dépend comme on l'a dit du client et il
se trouve que artemief est quand même
particulièrement lent ouais c'est sûr
regardez-moi ça quel procédant de plus
en finale de tour je peux vous dire que
Wesley sceaux il va pas la rater
celle-là
c'est du chaos ou c'est du chaos
un truc comme ça quoi
dans le dans les commentaires
merci voilà c'est bon
j'ai enlevé le son de l'arbitre
[Musique]
de décalage
voilà alors
[Musique]
donc 15 minutes 20 enchères avec
chaos donc intéressant donc on va vous
laisser une petite pause de quelques
minutes on a des pubs à vous mettre et
donc on revient d'ici trois quatre
minutes pour
le dénouement de cette ronde
donc à tout de suite merci nous suivre
tout de suite
[Musique]
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec j'ai pas
mis le score le score actualisé de 45
qui est revenu au score avec deux deux
donc là on va un peu comment ça se passe
au niveau des
[Musique]
au niveau des tirages au sort parce que
je sais on va voir vous allez voir
sous enveloppe entre guillemets tu vois
je pense qu'ils envoient un message
alors nous nous on va pas se voir nous
on sera on va voir une fois que la
partie quoi ouais j'ai l'impression
qu'on va pas être dans le secret des on
va pas faire un truc comme au loto tu
vois
je pense que si vous voulez voir allez
sur le stream anglais je pense qu'ils
ont sur le truc comme au loto mais là
[Musique]
donc on va voir vous inquiétez pas en
tourne 9 minutes je pense que ça va être
plus haut moi je dirais 11 minutes
je pense que Nakamura Nakamura pardon
fais OCS ça va être du 9 minutes
peut-être aussi mais en tout cas les
Blancs ont toujours 15 ans c'est
ça
ça y est il y a pas de problème toujours
tu as 15 c'est obligatoire c'est juste
le temps des Noirs où on met une enchère
celui qui a le plus bas prends les Noirs
donc on peut très bien mettre 15 minutes
[Musique]
alors en fait si je dis trois et 15.3
on va voir on va voir on va voir ce qui
se passe ouais pour l'instant on regarde
comme Magnus hein c'est dur de regarder
plusieurs parties en même temps Arnaud
de chaise mais il est passionnant ce
match on est bien tombé quatre victoires
avec des parties quand même bon certes
assez technique mais quand même des
belles parties clairement avec beaucoup
de contenu
donc oui non les blancs alors je sais
pas ce qui se passe si les deux mettent
la même chose ça c'est la question je
pense que c'est celui qui a été devant
au playing peut-être donc peut-être ou
celui qui est devant au classement
général donc je pense que c'est Magnus
qui prime en l'occurrence mais il y a
très certainement un règlement bon après
c'est un cas
ou alors on refait un tour de recherche
je sais pas comment ça marche
c'est
858 qui va pas mettre un truc con quoi
donc pour arriver quand même un truc
similaire il faut vraiment pas avoir de
chance quoi ouais après je sais pas je
sais pas ce que ça va donner on va voir
s'ils mettent le même score ça va être
le premier qui a envoyé
bon
du coup là j'ai pas encore mis les moi
j'ai pas encore changé les équipes là
les couleurs donc on attend
il aura les blancs
parce que ils sont contents ils sont
contents les deux les deux finalement
Artémis remarque
va être content parce que artemie a fait
mou quand même avec les blancs dans les
ouvertures et Artémis est content
d'avoir plus de temps vu que il joue à
deux à l'heure je pense que je pense que
il veut mettre la pression
donc il va il va jouer moi je pense que
c'est les enchères vont être très hautes
parce que artemief est pas intéressé
d'avoir les Noirs il y a pas envie
d'avoir peu de temps et d'être sous
pression comme ça
je sais pas bon après je peux me tromper
ça se trouve ça sera on verra moi c'est
ce que moi étant pas genre rapide je
mettrai une enchère très haute avec les
Noirs tu vois je mettrai du 12 13
minutes je pense
pas encore dans ces trucs mais en
division 3 ça marche pas donc je mettrai
du 12 13 minutes parce que j'aime bien
avoir du temps
9 minutes ça me paraît comme tu le dis
c'est du chaos j'aurais trop peur de me
faire flaguer
avec un incrément donc effectivement
je pense que les chances raisonnables
qui mettent quelque chose de très haut
on va voir après quand partait mieux
comme je sais qu'il doit il doit
activer un peu exactement tu vois donc
il est quand même là
aujourd'hui quand même
c'est sans et déplorable et c'est pas la
première fois sur internet il a fait ça
j'ai vu beaucoup de fois
être en grosse difficulté donc
voilà
alors en tout cas on va voir c'est
intéressant je vais essayer pour mettre
le son fait de l'arbitre on va prendre
des choses
une fois que c'est intéressant j'entends
pas quand tu mets le son
là je vois 1er jour de chez sebbay il y
a une sortie industrie vidéo regarde
regardez-moi ça je vous fais des choses
un peu de temps
ça va arriver ouais et on a donc ce qui
vient de sortir sur Fireball
12 heures de vidéo avec fire and board
monsieur fire and board avec ses girof
qui montre
30 ans de carrière à sacrifier des
pièces
à faire des attaques
incroyable donc voilà allez voir chez
nos amis de chez seber vous avez du
contenu vous voyez vous avez beaucoup
d'ouverture mais vous avez aussi du
milieu de jeu et des de la stratégie et
des finales c'est un peu tout
malheureusement c'est pas c'est pas s'il
prévoit de le mettre en français mais en
tout cas
c'était l'actualité à deux trois ans
c'est pas fait après tout ce qui est
échec anglais faut pas non plus être
bilingue pour acheter un truc il faut il
faut savoir que c'est quand même assez
accessible
le vocabulaire c'est pas
moi je me considère comme comme
quasiment bilingue
en anglais échec
est-ce que tu considères Kevin thérieux
comme quasiment bilingue échec je crois
pas je crois pas vu
comment il aime bien se vanter au niveau
de son anglais
j'ai pas trop une aventure là dedans
mais après je le connais pas trop je
l'ai pas trop entendu parler anglais
mais c'est vrai que
tu n'es pas trop entendu
j'ai vu l'autre fois productrice
espagnole à essayer de lui parler en
anglais je te raconte pas
Laurent qu'est-ce qu'elle dit
c'était vraiment
alors on voit pas bien la 8e on voit pas
bien là si vous voulez j'attends
j'attends la donc Nakamura qui a choisi
d'après Arnolds 9 30 voilà on voit ses
alentours de 9 minutes alors plus ou
moins mais 9 30 je pense que Magnus ça
va tomber à 11 11 30 voilà
mais j'ai pas la partie est-ce que c'est
moi qui bug ou est-ce que
je vois pas le temps
non mais
le temps qu'il y a sur la partie c'est
la partie de carbone
là c'est
carrément
sans surprise allez blanc et Magnus a
choisi 7 0 8 très très bas ah non pas
c'est de dire il a choisi peut-être 52
c'est très on sait pas le choix de de
artemie fait 7,52 c'est quand même c'est
du lourd il voulait vraiment avoir les
Noirs ok je me suis trompé sur son
enchère tu vois
je pensais que leur chair allait être
beaucoup plus haute mais cette 52 c'est
quand même très osé de la part de manus
Carson mais bon
on a une sorte de sicilienne hybride 4,5
G3 attends je couvre dans mon
en fait je vois qu'une partie là je vois
Caravana
je dois avoir
[Musique]
je joue très vite 27 contre 13,40 on a
une position fermée donc pour l'instant
ça commence
à aller j'ai bluebom fille j'ai carvana
j'ai pas cartonne
mais pourtant Carsen je le
je l'avais suivi là c'est les parties du
top rapide
ah peut-être que c'est peut-être que
c'est du bled
vu la
[Musique]
les enchères je les ai les enchères là
j'ai vu sur Twitter may muscu 758
et
Artémis 11 minutes donc voilà tu aimes
bien qu'il avait pas envie mal au temps
direct clairement
parce que celui qui fait nul a gagné
c'est un cas de nul c'est les noirs qui
gagnent ça Santiago
[Musique]
Santiago le Mira voilà c'est aussi
simple que ça donc en fait ça s'appelle
les draw hots donc en cas de en cas de
partie nulle c'est les noirs qui sont
vainqueurs du match donc évidemment
intéressant de d'avoir les Noirs mais
il y a un prix à payer
ce prix est de 7 minutes 02 pour
minuscule
je vous rappelle et on a la partie ah
super ok parce que du coup mais pour
revenir
on peut voir la game et voilà voilà game
elle est là et des 4 une sorte de 6e
fermée un bon choix pour artemief qui
met autant et donc il essaye vraiment de
de garder le maximum de pièces et de
mettre la pression sur RTI Artémis à 15
minutes ça ça change jamais et 15
minutes pour les blancs tandis que c'est
l'enchère et simplement du côté noir
donc
c'est assez simple finalement au début
ça surprend un peu mais en fait c'est
assez simple à comprendre est-ce qu'on
peut pas faire ou on peut se prendre un
F5 méchant ici
parce que je sens qu'il est méchant ou
pas non F5 a l'air d'aller faut toujours
faire attention F5 tu pourrais prendre
un G2 on va prendre les deux et puis on
prend F5 ça a l'air d'aller pour les
noirs
si la cadence est donnée sur chaise 24
Guyane parce qu'on voit premier coup de
réflexion 7 0 2 7 08 pour manuscrit deux
c'est à dire qu'il a mis 6 secondes à
jouer son premier coup mais voilà elle
est clairement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici Stéphane
ok intéressant et surpuis on prend je
suppose qu'il veut faire fouger 5 et
déstabiliser ce cavalière recette et
installer un cavalier le KFC 3 en D5
très intéressant choix très responsable
de la part de ladislavertemiev
qui fait quand même un très très gros
match attention Magnus 6 15 contre 10 55
bouge le cavalier va être forcé plus ou
moins de bouger oui il a raté ça il est
pas content
ec6 il va se prendre cahier des cinq et
après on va faire ces trois on me laisse
cavalier F6 et voilà
le cavalier en prison
et tout ça et c'est très chaud 3 8
jouets mais bon là je crois qu'on va
faire [__] 7 tours et cavaliers des 5
on a superbe cavalier en dessin est-ce
que je pourrais pas faire le même un
truc comme ça
pour bien sûr pour jouer contre ce fou
alors c'est pas gagnant encore mais les
blancs sont mieux ça c'est sûr après moi
je préférais ne pas en limite ne pas
prendre des cannes te faire cahier des 5
et comme ça je te fais ces trois et
comme ça tu as même pas tu as même pas
le contre-jeu éventuel dans ta ligne sur
le pion C2 tu vois et que c'est la
colonne c'est semi-ouvert quoi
peut-être éventuellement un contrôle
là-dessus sachant que la culture des cas
j'ai du mal à le C3 la case est
affaiblie alors du coup sans manger là
on peut le C3 et préparer par le
cavalier moins placé et puis il y a pas
le contrôle sur le petit donc il y a eu
faut prendre pour prendre Michael y a 5
comme tu disais
et ces trois qui va suivre et voilà on a
plus ce contre jeu éventuel comme tu le
dis il était pas tout de suite mais
je crois que ça va être ça va être chaud
ça va être dur pour Magnus là
avec 4 minutes 4 minutes en moins donc
il a fait un retard de son
de son temps du départ mais sa position
est pas variable en fait on joue vite
pour essayer de de rattraper le retard
qu'on a mais en jouant vite
on peut être amené à faire des erreurs
et là c'est la position blanche elle a
quand même assez bonne mais bon ça veut
rien dire là on a eu
bien de gagner quand même qui était
quand même quasiment perdu et il a il a
su
revenir dans la partie
donc il y a une façon bizarre de
réfléchir on a l'impression qu'il a
moitié assoupi
peut-être une randonnée trop longue ce
matin
ces trois est-ce que tu manges deux
est-ce que tu recules
est très très mal placé donc pour le
replacer en géant et 3
on sent que le cavalier a plus d'avenir
par là c'est hyper intéressant
c'est un truc
parce que quand on regarde les autres
pièces
les tours les tours sont très bien
placés sur la colonel la dame est bien
placée le Cay en dessin qui est
simplement un monstre il y a que ce
cavalier 2 comme tu le disais qui est
il y a pas trop d'avenir et donc ouais
on jouerache pour faire kaygien et
replacer ce cavalier alors c'est le coup
humain mais il se trouve que la jauge
n'aime pas c'est toujours comme ça
peut-être F5 peut-être quelque chose de
concret donc et c'est 7 ok je peux
régler ça j'aime pas du tout c'est 4 non
je peux même pas revenir là en fait
parce que on va venir pas manger
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux pas manger et faire
caca
et remettre quelque chose en descend
est-ce que c'est pas débile
je peux revenir ici
peut-être faut regarder pour aller en E3
et en D4 si je peux
assez concret les échecs qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
donc il y a beaucoup de choses à
calculer attention Artémis il le
rattrape autant là deux 30 d'avance
simplement pour et cancer
moi je l'ai pour la barbue faire du
Bullet
[Musique]
il est extrêmement rapide
je pense que des fois
qu'il est pas au niveau quand même pour
le flag mais
donc
c'est pas ce qu'on recherche
et manger là ça va offrir un pion un
pion passé à l'adversaire donc on a pas
envie de toucher
qu'est-ce que j'aime pas ça
ok donc là on peut faire un cahier
français tout simplement et c'est toi
qui a eu des 5 et on a très très beau
cavalier en dessin qui domine bien ce
fou G7
pareil compliqué pour
pour Magnus qui est définitivement moins
bien alors après
pas non plus complètement perdant c'est
sûr mais intéressant
est-ce que d'autres parties sont les
autres parties sont en cours avec
apparemment et Karuna Camara qui est
complètement foutu contre fédoce
complètement foutu purement purement
contre fedo CIF mais attention et Caro
Nakamura c'est un diable de la défense
et entre car on a et le Kang c'est en
train de bien se passer pour les coins
quoi que c'est compliqué le compte
qu'elle est blanc
c'est le coin qui allait noir les noirs
magnifique mais le problème c'est que
c'est du rapide donc on peut pas tout de
suite en même temps
pour installer cette batterie de
cavaliers on n'a pas tellement de casse
de
toute façon et je contrôle le mauvais
fou donc après F5 serait un coup mais
bon il y a tout qui s'ouvre je pense pas
que ça passe les affaires
avec les noirs
si je prends je le sens et
puis il t'attend et peut-être un F5 à au
bon moment il y a un mode défense
Carsen plus que c'est quand même la
bonne nouvelle
pour Magnus c'est le temps comme souvent
dans ce match
en grande difficulté clairement il faut
appeler
en ce match et RTBF montre une nouvelle
fois tout son talent
et c'est vrai que Artémis il a pas le
rythme aujourd'hui
tu as certainement raison
particulièrement endormi
il a l'air endormi mais là là tu vois
en fait car cette V8 la pression en
temps et puis il joue des coups défensif
quoi
il attend quoi sauf que là bon là il
faut qu'il joue un coup là
cavaler
en B8 C6 et D4 et les laisser se relais
des deux cavaliers qui en fait il y a un
cavalier de trop je l'aurais changé moi
ce cavalier
parce que tu as pas envie de d'avoir
deux taille il y a une seule case à
occuper clairement c'est la casse des 5
et donc on a un cavalier trop donc je
vois pas l'intérêt de garder les pièces
à part que on est obligé de gagner et
qu'on a envie de garder plus de pièces
bon ça c'est un autre raisonnement
mais il va aller en Descartes 353 contre
5 15 ça nous promet quelque chose de
assez
intéressants
ah oui effectivement oui je suis désolé
pour
pour notre ami
désolé
en D4 rapidement plus qu'une minute de
moins pour ma muscarsen qui clairement
et en train de passer la seconde là mais
il a commencé avec 7 minutes de moins
donc là il est quand même bien revenu au
temps
très important
ça vaut un pion c'est 7 minutes
B5 cavaliers des 4
pour voir s'il arrive à changer ce
cavalier mais bon
il va être gagnant il va il va se faire
c'est un scénario que je pourrais
clairement imaginer
à toi ça nous fait plaisir aussi de
revenir salut tous les jours toute la
semaine jusqu'à vendredi ouais et après
je pense que samedi dimanche c'est
dimanche je crois
comment je peux venir
[Musique]
donc bah vous avez des échecs tous les
jours pendant un mois quasi quasi tous
les jours sympa
puis pas des droits de seconde zone avec
ce championnat du monde qui arrive alors
évidemment il marque Magnus mais ça
reste quand même numéro 2 et 3 mondiaux
prestigieux
qui est des 8 en volant le 6 rapidement
[Musique]
on n'est pas obligé de prendre c'est la
règle des échecs
est-ce que je peux pas commencer par
tout reprendre F6 au lieu de
et du coup et ouais ah non je raconte
n'importe quoi faut prendre cavalier
manus Carlsen 20 secondes de moins avec
partie avec 7 minutes de moins plus que
20 secondes et bientôt il sera mis
autant on le sait on le sait tous H5
tours F7 qu'est-ce que je fais là je
fais puis on prend puis on prend et je
m'arrange avec Madame pour t'attaquer le
purge 6
peut-être peut-être aller dur à jouer
cette position il y a il a mal géré la
artemief il y a bien joué mais il joue
30 ans et puis là il y a quand même des
petits trucs tu vois il y a des petits
coups marlou hein il y a des petits
trucs qui peuvent arriver aussi ouais
mais bon il est plutôt là il y a plus de
temps et tu sais que ça gigote quoi
F5 allez Magnus ouais je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que c'est l'heure mais
est-ce que c'est jamais l'heure de F5 en
fait c'est ça
c'est à peu près pareil
mais plus de temps finalement pour
t'aimer sa position est mauvaise
personne
deux minutes mais c'est largement
suffisant pour une musclerc scène il est
tellement rapide ouais mais là c'est un
bit là c'est un
blés
finale de foot coréposer complètement
perdant on va voir s'il arrive à s'en
sortir une nouvelle fois mais ça a l'air
ça a l'air fini
ok les blancs doivent gagner et Artemis
à faire moins de temps et une position
il vient de se faire arnaquer avec F4
aussi tout simplement pour le fabuleux
joueur russe mais attention il a été euh
cavalier des quatre je vais tout prendre
donc c'est ça en fait le problème en
fait
tellement il est bien en ce qui compte
tu as les noms dans le chat
et on rappelle les blancs sont obligés
de gagner mais là c'est mort c'est mort
en plus il est cuit dur maintenant sur
la position il a un pion de moins et
remarque
monstrueux en dessin mais quand même
mais quand même ça paraît très très
douteux
allez on est en dessous de la minute
on le sait un manuscrite
c'est pas raisonnable ce qui nous fait
artemief juste bouger le fou et il va
utiliser le clouage
fois 6 fois 6
non mais là c'est juste 48 secondes ça
va pas il n'a qu'à sauve non mais non
retourne en situation
très certainement on ira voir la fin de
cette partie là
c'est cuit 37 secondes
[Musique]
on n'a pas envie de voir ça
incroyable évidemment il va le flaguer
il va être foutu il va le flinguer
sa dame
[Rires]
tellement c'est énorme
allez allez
c'est énorme on va voir on va voir
c'est le drame de l'armée
qui a été vraiment en sueur toute toute
la journée la tour G5 est-ce qu'il va
faire ouais qui joue vite 20 secondes
[Musique]
contre 30 secondes
avec cette seconde à la pendule avec un
scène qui passe
au final énorme gaffe de grosse
j'ai pas eu
alors je vais vous dire ça tout de suite
sorti sur un pas de venu de l'espace
incroyable incroyable car on a qu'à moi
qui revient qui était à selon la jauge à
moins 8,67 - 9 72 signale de foot quoi
reposer archi foutu
incroyable les manuscarsen qui perd
aussi
j'ai un petit souci sur
j'arrive pas à retrouver les parties
donc on peut la retrouver ici cette
partie si vous voulez de de Naka
ouais en fait il a poussé on va regarder
je vais la mettre en accéléré
on a la finale est très intéressante
ou on va on va montrer ce qu'il a raté
en fait ça gagne
c'était pas si simple peut-être
incroyable oui en fait le pion blanc
gêne assez joli
c'est assez joli ce qui s'est passé
incroyable sur la caméra
Big Fish
contre Nakamura
[Musique]
tout le temps
à chaque fois que je devrais jouer j'ai
l'impression que c'est non
en tout cas là
en plus là autant il est encore quand
même 7,50 contre 5 minutes quoi
il faut qu'il gagne mais
[Musique]
Nakamura on va voir on va voir la finale
de football je pense qu'il a bien
converti jusqu'à
ouais ben voilà il prend un deuxième
pion il est complètement gagnant
évidemment
on a la paire de fou certes mais c'est
depuis
et donc comment il a fait là ok il a
joué quand même il a réussi à pousser au
monde
et voilà on voit cette fameuse dont je
vous parlais ouais il a [__] opposé
mais
trop de pions de moins
mais on va voir
en fait si mais il faut pas pousser il a
poussé trop son
en fait il suffit qu'il aille ramasser
le fou maintenant
B6 c'est une énorme gaffe parce que
maintenant ça crée des thèmes vous allez
voir
et exactement c'est ce qui s'est passé
dans la partie il fallait pas pousser le
pion
en B6 c'est un cauchemar maintenant pour
en fait
c'est bon
horreur pour
ambre rose
il a deux minutes contre une
un truc comme ça et il se prend en un
coup une découverte hyper la dame et
les noirs
incroyable ce qui s'est passé et là
aussi c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé donc du coup on a qui on a Fabien
ocarwana Wesley kamura et artemief qui
se qualifie pour le
service final du winners bracket aura
une chance en plus demain
donc
dans le tableau principal on va artemief
qui va jouer contre Caravana on aura
fait dossier pardon
Nakamura il va jouer contre
et dans le dans la petite finale ça veut
dire dans la
consolante on aura 15 chaînes
contre
et
fais de CF contre aronial
je pense que c'est le les coins qui
perdent
la consolante tu reviens dans le tableau
et tu as encore une chance
donc voilà voilà
[Musique]
félicitations à lui clairement c'est pas
donné à tout le monde de battre dans un
match comme ça en quatre parties rapides
et des partages éventuels et il a été et
en plus on l'a trouvé un petit peu
endormie donc ça ça veut dire que il est
arrivé à quand même sous le sous le pied
notre ami
en tout cas nous on est de retour demain
alors normalement à 17h mais il est
possible qu'on soit demain là un peu
plus tôt avec avec Laurent parce qu'on
voulait voir peut-être le match de
Denver je sais pas à quelle heure il est
il faut qu'on regarde parce que je sais
que
c'est 16h on sera sûrement là donc
voilà donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi le
stream on va partir avec un petit raid
je vais je vais être mon ami
notre ami
bien sûr
et puis nous à partir de 16h demain on
est on est là donc merci à tous merci à
toi Laurent et à demain merci à tous
nous avoir suivis et à demain pour de
nouvelles aventures à demain
mais je crois qu'il est pas parti
je crois que ça part
on est parti je vois qu'il y a sur le
apparemment c'est parti
mais non
je sais pas bon
il est parti
ouais bon merci à tous bonne soirée à
bientôt